madame Amélie oua Castera ministre des
Sports et des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques madame la ministre je vous
souhaite la bienvenue et vous remercie
de votre disponibilité pour répondre à
nos
questions nous avons entamé les travaux
de cette commission d'enquête soit
l'identification des défaillances de
fonctionnement au sein des fédérations
françaises de sport du monde sportif et
des organismes de gouvernance du monde
sportif le 20 juillet dernier
l'Assemblée nationale a décidé de sa
création à la suite de très nombreuses
révélations publiques de sportives et
sportifs et de diverses affaires
judiciaires ayant tra à la gestion de
certaines
fédérations nos travaux portent donc sur
trois axes les violence physique
sexuelle ou psychologique dans le sport
les discriminations sexuelles et
raciales et les problématiques liées à
la gouvernance financière des organismes
de gouvernance du monde sportif madame
la ministre vous avez notamment été
joueuse de tennis professionnel et
directrice générale de la Fédération
Française de Tennis de mars 2021 à
juillet 2022 vous avez a également fondé
et présider l'association rénovons le
sport français vous êtes depuis juillet
2022 ministre des Sports et des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques madame la
ministre vous connaissez de l'intérieur
le fonctionnement d'une fédération et
les relations qui existent entre une
fédération et le ministère vous avez eu
à gérer des crises majeures au sein de
plusieurs
fédérations nos travaux ont permis de
mettre en avant le chemin par
depuis 2020 tout le monde s'accorde à
dire qu'il y a eu un avant et un après
cependant nos travaux montrent
clairement que nous ne sommes pas au
bout du chemin et l'objectif est de
formuler des préconisations utiles sur
ce sujet
majeur à cet égard nous nous interrogons
sur la capacité du ministère des Sports
dans l'organisation qui est la sienne à
exercer des contrôles qui s'imposent sur
les acteurs du monde sportif
votre prédécesseuse madame Roxana
marinanou a rappelé que la ministre doit
veiller au contrôle strict de la loi et
des décrets mais àter certaines
difficultés disposez-vous des moyens de
faire appliquer les textes qui existent
déjà dans les domaines qui intéressent
notre commission nous nous interrogons
sur les capacité d'action concrète du
ministère face à une fédération qui
dysfonctionnerait
madame marassinanou a souligné la
volonté du ministère d'être exigeant
dans la délégation de service public
donné à une fédération et de se donner
les moyens de contrôler l'exécution des
contrats de
délégation cet objectif est-il atteint
disposez-vous des leviers nécessaires
pour garantir que l'action du CNOSF ou
encore de l'Agence nationale du sport
puisse venir compléter et non
concurrencer celle du
ministère nous avons constaté des
dysfonctionnements importants importants
pardon que l'État ne peut ignorer quel
chantier êtes-vous prête à ouvrir pour y
remédier l'heure n'est-elle pas un
besoin accru d'État garant de l'intérêt
général je rappelle que cette audition
est ouverte à la presse et qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale et avant de vous
laisser la parole et d'entamer nos
échanges je vous rappelle que l'article
6 de l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes entendues par une commission
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous invite donc à lever la
main droite et à dire je le jure après
avoir activé votre
micro je le jure je vous remercie madame
la ministre vous avez la parole pour euh
prenez le temps d' minutes un quart
d'heure et ensuite nous aurons bien sûr
des des questions pour euh pour échanger
avec vous
merci je vous remercie madame la
présidente Madame la rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les députés je veux d'abord
vous remercier pour me donner cette
occasion d'échanger avec vous sur ces
sujets qui sont cruciaux pour l'avenir
du sport depuis les premiers pas de vos
travaux en juillet les témoignages que
vous avez recueillis à forceuie les plus
poignants d'entre eux renforce chez moi
une double conviction la première c'est
que le sport à l'instar d'autres
composantes de notre société et le
théâtre de violence de dérives qui sont
en soi inacceptables et qui doivent être
combattu avec d'autant plus de
volontarisme qu'elles peuvent sinon
jeter l'eau probre sur tout un secteur
en abîant parfois en décrédibilisant ce
que le sport a pourtant d'essentiel à
apporter à notre société la seconde
c'est que pour mettre un terme à ces
violences à ses dérives mais aussi à
leur complice de toujours l'omerta la
passivité parfois même la complaisance
souvent l'inere merci nous devons
rassembler les forces vives déterminées
à lutter contre elles appeler chacun à
prendre ses responsabilités et ne rien
laisser passer c'est ce que je m'efforce
de faire sans relâche depuis le premier
jour à la tête de mon ministère le 20
mai 2022 et je sais que c'est à votre
façon ce que vous vous efforcez de faire
depuis le 20 juillet votre commission a
auditionné de nombreuses personnalités
sur plusieurs enjeux majeurs qui sont
autant d'impératif pour le sport
français la lutte contre les violences
c'est tout particulièrement les
violences sexuelles la lutte contre
toutes les formes de discrimination la
lutte contre d'autres formes d'atteintte
à l'éthique ou à l'intégrité qu'elle
soit morale ou financière et
l'amélioration de la gouvernance des
fédérations je souhaite dans cet exposé
rappeler sur ces thématique quelques-uns
des combats qui ont été les miens les
avancées obtenues et la manière dont
j'entends poursuivre mon action à
commencé par la bataille la plus vitale
la plus urgente à remporter celle contre
les violences à caractère sexiste et
sexuel ces dernières années la
déflagration Mitou tout a permis
d'amorcer une libération de la parole
avec les pionnières qu'on été Catherine
Moyon de becec Isabelle de monjau avec
elle sont venu Sarah bitb angélique
Kochi Sébastien by et encore beaucoup
d'autres beaucoup trop d'autres victimes
plus anonymes à qui je veux redire ici
mon admiration pour le courage qu'elles
ont eu doser un jour briser le silence
certaines de ces victimes sont venu
témoigner ici devant vous pour faire en
sorte que d'autres n'aient plus à vivre
à leur tour la solitude la peur la
douleur l' coméhension la colère le
cauchemar qui ont été les leurs merci à
elle leur combat est devenu notre combat
face à ces révélations l'État a pris ses
responsabilités depuis 2020 sous
l'autorité du Président de la République
les gouvernements successifs que ce soit
ceux d'Édouard Philippe de Jean Castex
aujourd'hui d'Élisabeth borne se sont
mobilisés comme jamais sur ces sujets je
veux bien sûr rendre un hommage tout
particulier à ma prédécesseur Roxana
marassin àou pour avoir engagé comme
elle l'a fait cette bataille même s'il
reste beaucoup de travail je veux
souligner qu'une véritable révolution a
été opérée entre 19 entre 2019 et 2022
avec la création de laal de la cellule
signal sport la désignation d'une
déléguée ministérielle à la lutte contre
les violences les conventions organisées
chaque année contre ces violences dans
le sport la Constitution dans nos
fédérations sportives et nos
établissements sportifs d'un réseau de
référence spécialisé le développement
l'outillage du contrôle d'honorabilité
l'inscription dans la loi de
l'obligation de formation en matière de
violence sexiste et sexuelle dans le cas
de tous les diplômes d'état jeunesse et
sport et dès mon arrivée j'ai fait mien
ce combat avec une ligne clair tolérance
zéro en érigeant la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles au rang de priorité
de mon ministère en sollicitant et en
obtenant des moyens humains inédits avec
20 effectifs supplémentaires en 2023 et
à nouveau 36 dans le PLF 2024 pour que
les enquêtes aillent plus vite tout en
renforçant le contrôle des
établissements sportifs j'ai fait preuve
d'une fermeté totale lorsqu'il s'est
agit de traiter des situations de crise
au sein des fédérations y compris les
plus puissant d'entre elles comme la
fédération de foot de taper du point sur
la table pour que les instances prennent
leur responsabilités ou pour interpeller
leur président pour lancer relancer
parfois des inspections en sollicitant
là aussi plus que jamais fortement
l'igsr l'inspection générale et en
saisissant la justice par la voix de
l'article 40 chaque fois que nous le
jugions nécessaire j'ai milité pour que
s'améliore l'articulation entre les
procédures judiciaires administratives
disciplinaires et nous avons ainsi avec
le garde des saut déployé pour la
première fois des références sport au
sein des parquets grâce à la circulaire
de mai 23 j'ai impulsé des temps
renforcés de prise de conscience de
mobilisation avec tous les acteurs du du
sport et les professions qui l'entourent
par exemple en ajoutant aux conventions
annuelles un séminaire dédié à la
question de l'enfant face aux violences
dans le sport début
2023 avec tout cela nous avons déjà des
acquis au 2 novembre 2023 plus de 1800
signalement ont été traités par signal
sport mettant en cause plus de 1200
personnes donnant lieu à 266 arrêtés
d'interdiction d'exercer en urgence 126
arrêtés d'interdiction d'exercer pérenne
notification d'incapacité d'exercer
suite à condamnation
pénale et toujours sur ce plan des
acquis nous avons améliorer la portée du
contrôle d'honorabilité en le
systématisant de manière beaucoup plus
rigoureuse à tous les éducateurs
sportifs professionnel et en l'étendant
de manière plus effective à tous les
bénévoles notamment ceux en contact des
mineurs avec aussi novembre 2023 déjà
plus de 100 mlion2 d'identifiés
d'identités de bénévoles contre ô j'ai
par ailleurs
décidé de passer le nombre de contrôle
des établissements d'activités physique
et sportive de
3900 à 6000 en 2024 grâce au renfort
obtenu soit une hausse de 54
%. alors bien sûr mesdames et messieurs
les députés bien sûr madame la
rapporteur bien sûr madame la Présidente
on n'est pas au bout du chemin bien sûr
loin s'en faut
et le travail doit se poursuivre je vois
pour cela CIN axes prioritaires d'abord
continuer à marteler l'obligation de
signalement pour que chacun comprenne
que signaler ce type de violence ça
n'est pas une option mais une obligation
responsabiliser en ce sens chaque acteur
de la chaîne que ce soit dans le sport
amateur ou dans le sport
professionnel mieux faire connaître le
canal de signal sport c'est l'un des
enseignements que nous tirons
collectivement des trau de votre
commission mieux faire connaître signal
sport partout et tout le temps nous
devons continuer de sécuriser une
meilleure articulation entre les
procédures et faire en sorte d'engager
nos fédérations à aller au bout de leur
responsabilités en matière
disciplinaire il nous faut parachever le
système de contrôle d'honorabilité et
mettre fin ainsi aux derniers angles
morts au contournements qui peuvent
encore ça et là
exister
on doit enfin mieux accompagner les
victimes tant dans leur démarche
judiciaire que pour leur reconstruction
en lien avec les association de victimes
et l'environnement familial qui a un
rôle une place à respecter et à
accompagner alors au-delà des violences
à caractère sexiste et sexuel j'ai
souhaité aussi mener une action
déterminé résolu contre toutes les
formes de dérives dans le sport d'abord
en matière de lutte contre les
maltraitants
en faisant en sorte qu'elle soit
éradiquée de notre culture de la haute
performance comme je l'ai exigé avec
force par exemple dans la gymnastique
ensuite en matière de lutte contre les
violences dans les stades avec de
nombreuses actions engagées depuis un an
en lien avec le ministère de l'Intérieur
la Ligue de foot professionnelle et
notamment grâce à une relance de
l'instance nationale du supporteurisme
en renforçant le rôle des référents
supporters et celui des policiers
référents supporters visiteurs
en systématisant les interdictions
judiciaires de stade pour les les
infractions les plus graves en lien avec
les manifestations sportives violence
physique provocation à la haine ou à la
violence en créant de nouveaux délit
s'agissant de l'entrée par force ou par
fraude dans les enceintes et de
l'intrusion sans motif légitime sur
l'air de
compétition j'ai souhaité en outre
renforcer la lutte contre toutes les les
formes de discrimination en veillant à
ce que les faits soient systématiquement
relevés les auteurs identifiés et les
sanctions les plus sévèrement prononcé
en formant 100 % des éducateurs sportifs
à la lutte contre le racisme
l'antisémitisme et les discriminations
liées à
l'origine s'agissant de la lutte contre
les violences dont sont victimes les
personnes LGBT dans le sport j'ai
présenté le 17 mai 2023 un plan d'action
extrêmement volontariste
avec un appel à la mise en place
d'instances dédiées au cœur des
fédérations pour lutter contre ces
discriminations sur le modèle de la
cadette dans le
rugby avec la remontée systématique sur
la feuille de match de tous les actes
discriminatoires qui se produiraient en
tribune ou sur le
terrain en écrivant dans un courrier le
12 octobre dernier au président de club
à tous les dirigeants de ces clubs pour
leur demander d'agir plus fortement pour
prévenir l'homophobie dans dans les
stades en lien avec les associations de
supporters j'ai demandé que les
protocoles prévus lors des rencontres
soient activés chaque fois que
nécessaire y compris en suspendant un
match voire en l'arrêtant en cas de
champ homophobe et dans le même temps
j'ai veillé à ouvrir la pratique
sportive au plus grand nombre dans une
logique d'inclusion par exemple en
remettant le 9 septembre dernier un
agrément ministériel à la fédération
sportive
lgbt+ alors je ne laisserai pas dire un
instant par quiconque que mon action à
la matière serait partielle ou
superficielle j'ai fait sur ce registre
beaucoup plus qu'aucun dirigeant sportif
n'avait fait avant
moi sur le sujet du harcèlement dans le
cadre du plan interministériel que nous
avons porté le 27 septembre dernier
autour de la première ministre j'ai
souhaité là encore que le sport prenne
toute sa place avec cinq familles
d'acteurs que j'ai impliqué dans le
champ sportif les éducateurs sportifs
les fédérations l'inspection générale
les centres d'entraînement et de
formation les plateformes
numériques pour promouvoir l'intégrité
totale du sport j'ai œuvré sur deux
autres dimensions qui sont au cœur des
missions de service public du sport la
prévention et la lutte contre le dopage
en dotant la FLD de moyens inédits en
parachevant notre édifice juridique de
protection également dans le domaine de
la lutte contre la manipulation des
compétitions sportives
enfin même si vos travaux ne portent pas
spécifiquement sur ce point j'ai
souhaité une action ferme et déterminée
contre toutes les dérives séparatistes
en rehaussant les moyens affectés à ces
enjeux partout dans le champ
sportif alors sur le plan de la
gouvernance maintenant c'est cette
dernière partie que je veux évoquer avec
vous la gouvernance des fédérations
juste avant mon arrivée au ministère une
réforme importante de cette gouver
avait été opéré par la loi du 2 mars
2022 comportant plusieurs améliorations
en matière de limitation des mandats de
transparence et de
déontologie de vitalité démocratique
avec le vote direct des clubs j'ai
accompagné chacune des fédérations dans
la mise en œuvre effective de ces
mesures dans le même temps j'ai opéré
une clarification des rôles et des
responsabilités de l'ensemble des
acteurs en recentrant mon minist sur ces
missions régaliennes et d'évaluation et
en rendant beaucoup plus claires les
frontières de compétences entre la
direction des sports et l'Agence
nationale du sport y compris par des
protocoles
détaillés lors des crises que j'ai eu à
traverser je suis intervenu à chaque
fois pour m'assurer du respect par
chaque acteur de ses obligations et
responsabilités et pour appeler au bon
fonctionnement éthique et démocratique
des
instances collectivement nous en avons
tiré un retour tour d'expérience sur ce
qui peut dans la vie fédérale conduire à
des défaillances ce qui peut aussi les
prévenir et ce qui peut les faire cesser
et oui bien entendu ces crises de nature
et de cause diverses m'ont conduitite à
approfondir la réflexion sur le
renforcement de nos institutions
sportives j'ai ainsi pris l'initiative
d'installer dès le 29 mars dernier un
comité national pour le renforcement de
l'éthique et de la vie démocratique
confié à Marie-George Buffet et à
Stéphane Diagana en leur demandant leurs
recommandations sur trois thématique une
gouvernance du sport plus éthique une
meilleure vitalité démocratique une
protection renforcée des praticantes et
des pratiquants notamment contre toutes
les formes de violence et de
discrimination les préconisations de ce
comité me seront transmises
prochainement elles viendront nourrir
avec les conclusions de vos propres
travaux les modifications souhaitable du
cadre juridique du sport français en
lien avec les acteurs du sport je ne
vais pas préempter leurs conclusions
mais je peux partager quelques-uns des
principes directeurs qui à mon sens
doivent guider l'effort d'amélioration
de cette gouvernance des fédérations le
renforcement des comité d'éthique
s'assurer qu'il y a des contrepouvoirs
effectifs au cœur des instances inscrire
la protection des licenciés et la
préservation de l'éthique de l'intégrité
au frontispice des missions des
fédérations et au cœur du dialogue de
gestion que nous avons avec elle
améliorer aussi les voies de résolution
des conflits avec les bonnes cordes de
rappel démocratiqu et juridiques en cas
de blocage des institutions
ou de défaillance majeur de leur
dirigeants enfin mieux accompagner les
petites fédérations avec un rôle
renforcé aussi du
CNOSF en
conclusion mesdames et messieurs les
députés vous l'avez compris ma
détermination est totale et je ne
lâcherai rien sur aucun de ces combat
qui sont aussi les vôtres qu'il s'agisse
de lutte contre les violences de
discrimination ou de remédier aux
défaillances observées dans la
gouvernance ou le pilotage de nos
fédérations je continuerai à regarder en
face tout ce qui dans notre modèle
mérite d'être réparé corrigé amélioré y
compris au cœur de mon ministère pour
que le sport puisse tenir ses promesses
pour le libérer des mots qui le rongent
encore trop souvent et parce que la
lutte pour l'éthique et l'intégrité sont
depuis des années au fondement même de
mon engagement dans le sport dans cette
démarche je souhaite que nous ayons
également collectivement le discernement
la justesse de souligner aussi ce qui va
bien ce qui va déjà beaucoup mieux et
même ce qui est fort dans la gouvernance
du sport français parce qu'il y a sur
ces plans aussi beaucoup à dire de
l'engagement de nos 3,5 millions de de
bénévoolle à la vitalité de nos 180000
clubs à travers les territoires en
passant par la performance parfois
exceptionnelle de nos équipes de France
et le dévouement la probité l'engagement
de tant de dirigeants dans les
fédérations les ligues les comités les
clubs alors oui au côté de la
représentation nationale je continuerai
nous continuerons à fortifier ensemble
ce modèle sportif français qui en a
besoin et qui le mérite je me tiens
maintenant à votre disposition pour vos
questions tout en précisant que je suis
légalement tenu à ne pas évoquer des
affaires judiciaires en cours et à ne
pas méconnaître les obligations de
déport qui sont les mienne je vous
remercie
beaucoup merci madame la ministre je je
valide vos propos en tant qu'en plus élu
au sport et bénévole dans un club
sportif donc je remercie grandement le
mouvement sportif et les nombreux
bénévoles qui permettent bien sûr
d'animer ce mouvement sportif notamment
sur nos territoire au sein de nos nos
différentes associations donc vous avez
1000 fois raison sur sur à valoriser
bien sûr l'engagement de chacun d'entre
nous pour autant vous l'avez dit
vous-même tout à l'heure la cellule
signale sport entre autres nos travaux
sont sans appel sur l'insuffisance
visibilité de la cellule signal sport
même si on reconnaît bien sûr qu' c'est
une volonté de votre prédécesseuse et de
vous-même et que c'est une très bonne
chose hein on envoie un signal fort bien
sûr au au signalement aux victimes et
aux erreurs dans au dysfonctionnement au
sein des fédérations je voudrais juste
que on en a parlé ce matin avec Madame
Bourdet euh on peut que partager ce
constat et euh on a envie de dire
comment envisager une action pour y
remédier pour donner plus de visibilité
à cette cellule qui fait un son travail
qui a l'avantage aussi de de recueillir
les témoignages les dysfonctionnements
comme je le disais mais également
d'aiguiller derrière vers les
associations qui peuvent recueillir et
accompagner les les les témoignages et
donc les victimes mais également des
professionnels de santé donc bien
évidemment ce qu'on cherche avant tout
c'est de c'est de développer en même
temps et donner accès à cette cellule
signal sport au plus grand nombre et
puis une question qui suit bien sûr sur
signal sport le ministère du sport
peut-il imposer aux fédérations au
sportifs
l'affichage dans l'ensemble de leur club
de la plaquette du ministère relative à
la prévention des violences sexuelles
dans le sport et je terminerai par un
point donné par Monsieur David
laappartien qui a déclaré il faut qu'il
y ait plus de moyens sur cette cellule
sinon elle ne peut pas fonctionner
madame Bourdet a évoqué ce matin des
difficultés par le passé une situation
tendue envisagez-vous de renforcer les
moyens de cette
cellule
merci madame la
Présidente
pour accélérer sur la visibilité de
signal sport j'ai d'ors et déjà impulsé
plusieurs action importantes notamment
notre site internet a été totalement
modifié
avec un encart en haut à droite signaler
des violences et lorsque vous cliquez
dessus des pages explicativ des vidéos
explicatives une FAQ qui permet
d'expliquer le fonctionnement de signal
sport qui il concerne qui il peut par
qui il peut être
activé ces actions sont venues renforcer
de premières initiatives qui avaient été
prises à travers un certain nombre de
dépliant à travers une vidéo qui avait
été faite également en
2022 et j'ai jugé compte tenu des
témoignages dans le cadre de cette
commission d'enquête qu'il était de mon
devoir d'écrire une lettre
spécifiquement au directeur général de
l'Insep ce que j'ai fait dès le 11
octobre dernier d'écrire également de
faire écrire par la directrice des
Sports à l'ensemble des établissements
ce qu'elle a fait le 9 novembre dernier
pour que puisse être absolument renforcé
l'information sur l'existence de la
plateforme sur ses modalités de
fonctionnement et qu'au-delà de ces
enjeux de communication il y ait aussi
une amélioration de la pédagogie autour
des circuits de signalement autour des
modalités de prise en charge des
victimes et autour de la prévention de
toutes les situations à
risque j'ai souhaitit enclencher
également une vaste campagne de
communication qui s enclenchera au tout
début de l'année 2024 qui est une année
de grande cause pour le sport et cette
lutte contre les violences en fera
partie intégrante et qui se traduira
notamment par la diffusion de nouveaux
contenus notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux mais aussi auprès des
collectivité territoriale afin d'assurer
cette visibilité accrue de nos outils de
signalement et d'accompagnement des
victimes dans tous les lieux de pratique
donc oui affichage dans l'ensemble de
nos club en
France s'agissant des
moyens vous savez que j'ai demandé ces
renforts d'effectifs vous savez que je
les ai obtenu 20 effectifs sur
l'exercice
2023 36 effectifs sur l'exercice
2024 ça ne s'était jamais vu dans les
dernières années au ministère des sports
un certain nombre de ces emplois ont été
pourvus pas encore tous j'ai demandé une
accélération 15 des 20 ont d'ors et déjà
été déployés et je veux que dans
laallocation que nous avons prévu des 36
prochains effectifs on en est 20 dédiés
aux violences à caractère sexiste et
sexuel et les 16 autres à la prise en
charge d'un certain nombre de missions
de pilotage et d'accompagn plus
transversal je crois aujourd'hui que la
cellule signale sport au sein de
l'administration centrale du ministère
dans la sous-direction dédiée et avec
l'équipe dédiée complétée par celle en
charge du contrôle d'honorabilité a
désormais les moyens de de tenir sa
mission correctement l'enjeu était pour
moi de renforcer les services
déconcentrés pour faire en sorte qu'il y
ait beaucoup plus d'enquêtes qui puisse
être déclenché plus rapidement et
qu'elle puisse être mené avec davantage
de diligence que le contrôle également
des EAPS soit mené avec plus de force y
compris en terme de contrôle de
l'effectivité des notifications
d'incapacité d'exercer ou d'interdiction
d'exercer prises par les différents
préfets donc ce mouvement l'existence de
cette plateforme est en soi une force du
sport français
souligné par la civise qui a des points
de comparaison souligné par la Défenseur
des droits des enfant qui présente le
sport en la matière comme un exemple à
suivre mais oui il y a un enjeu
d'appropriation sur lequel nous devons
tous ensemble accélérer et je me réjouis
qu'en ce sens la proposition de loi du
sénateur Sébastien
plat qui date qui a été voté à
l'unanimité le 15 juin dernier au Sénat
consacre dans la loi l'obligation de
signalement sur le plan administratif du
club vers le préfet de la Fédération
vers le ministère et ce faisant nous
ancrons cette obligation administrative
de signaler qui vient compléter une
obligation pénale qui préexistait
article
434-3 du code pénal qui fait obligation
de saisir la justice lorsqu'on est face
à de telles violences face aux mineurs
article 40 du code de procédure pénale
qui oblige des autorités publiques à
dénoncer des situations de crime ou de
délit le périmètre de la cellule signal
sport n'est pas très clair pour tout le
monde et de nombreux signalement hors de
son ch champ de compétence arrivrive à
la plateforme envisagez-vous d'étendre
le périmètre de cette cellule à toutes
les violences et les discriminations et
je pense bien sûr au racisme à
l'homophobie certaines associations nous
ont dit avoir témoigné sans réponse sauf
la veille de l'urodition ici donc
avez-vous l'intention d'élargir les les
la possibilité de témoigner les
compétences de cette
cellule je pense que ce qui est très
important c'est d'affirmer et de
marteler ce que je vais appeler avec
vous le tout sauf c'est quoi le tout
sauf de signal sport c'est que signal
sport doit embarquer tout sauf en
matière de violence à caractère sexiste
et sexuel ce qui est du ressort des
rapports entre particuliers d'un
licencié d'un pratiquant à un autre ou
les rapports entre des sportifs qui eux
relève d'autres procédures judiciaires
les unes judiciaires et ou
disciplinaires pour les
autres ce
champ-l il faut absolument qu'il soit
parfaitement clair pour chacun des
acteurs et l'obligation de signalement
que j'évoqué tout à l'heure qui peut
être demain consacré par la loi nous
permettra de rendre parfaitement clair
cet élément et je complète par rapport à
votre seconde question sur le sujet des
discriminations aujourd'hui mon
sentiment est que l'action de la dilcra
l'action du Défenseur des droits et
l'action des
tribunaux permet d'absorber le flux en
la matière dès lors dès lors et
j'insiste que l'ensemble des instances
des ligues professionnelles des
fédération les ensembles des instances
disciplinaires exercent jusqu'au bout
leur
responsabilité nous avons renforcé notre
arsenal juridique et législatif pour
dénoncer ces discriminations nous avons
inscrit la formation contre ces
discriminations au cœur du pilotage des
diplômes jeunesse et sport je pense
qu'en la matière c'est une volonté et un
sursaut collectif culturel qu'il faut
d'abord
traiter juste pour bien éclaircir la
réponse et parce qu'on se pose à côté de
la la même
question si c'est oui ou si non parce
que Monsieur Olivier cllein par exemple
la dilc nous a indiqué avoir demandé une
extension du périmètre de la cellule au
racisme et discrimination le
confirmez-vous et et donc est-ce que
c'est un oui quel suite à donneré à la
position de je n'ai pas eu moi-même
connaissance de cette demande je l'ai lu
et je l'ai entendu dans vos travaux mais
elle ne m'a pas été adressée à moi
personnellement et mon sentiment
aujourd'hui
et que l'urgence est de permettre à
Signal sport d'aller au bout du sujet
des violences à caractère sexiste et
sexuel des violences liées à la
maltraitance physique ou psychologique
et je pense qu'il est préférable de
s'appuyer sur les instances existantes
disciplinaires et judiciaires pour
aborder la question de la lutte contre
les discrimination maintenant je suis
ouverte à la poursuite de cette
réflexion dans le cadre des TR qui
seront les votres vos conclusions ainsi
que celles
de du comité pour l'éthique et la vie
démocratique alors comme vous le savez
madame la ministre il faut libérer le
micro pour permettre à Madame la
rapporteur de prendre la
main
merci du coup madame la ministre en fait
ce que j'entends en tout cas ce que je
comprends c'est que vous n'êtes pas
forcément favorable maintenant à élargir
le périmètre de travail de la cellule
signal sport sauf que vous voyez dans le
cadre des auditions que ce soit la
dilcra ou même d'autres associations
justement la demande a été faite de
pouvoir élargir le périmètre de cette
cellule afin que tous les signalements
arrivent là-dessus puisqu'on parle des
instances qui existent sauf qu'ell
n'existent pas partout en tout
cas il y a certaines fédération qui
trait pas les sujets de la même manière
donc forcément c'est très différent
d'une fédération à l'autre dans le
traitement des affaires et des
finalement qui sont effectués et les
associations d'ailleurs certaines nous
ont dit qu'elles avaient obtenu des
réponses notamment sur des faits en lien
avec des actes d'homophobie elles
avaient obtenu des réponses de la
cellule signal sport la veille de leur
audition donc ça veut dire que quelque
part c'est possible c'està-dire qu'on
peut faire des signalements maintenant
la question c'est est-ce qu'on est prêt
à élargir le traitement de ces
signalements y compris sur d'autres
champs que celui des
VSS je comprends
votre votre question je redis que
aujourd'hui lorsque ces
discriminations nous parviennent sur la
plateforme nous ne les laissons pas de
côté nous les prenons en charge et nous
les inscrivons dans les circuits de
traitement mais je pense que il
faut mettre des priorités sur les
priorités et je pense que quand on voit
l'ampleur des défis qui restent les
nôtres en matière d'éradication des
violences à caractère sexiste et sexuel
celles-ci doivent rester la
priorité dans le
traitement tant à l'échelon central qu'à
l'échelon déconcentré en complément
d'autres missions sur lesquelles j'ai
demandé la vigilance la plus extrême
notamment le repérage des signaux
faibles de
séparatisme donc je pense aujourd'hui
que sur ces sujet là de discrimination
encore une fois nous prenons notre part
nous ne laissons pas non répondu c'estes
remonté là mais c'est d'abord les
instances disciplinaires et la justice
quand elle est saisie y compris par la
voie d'article 40 si nécessaire qui
doivent être mises le plus en avant
possible merci mais alors justement
c'est là où je pense qu'il y a une vraie
difficulté parce que le fait de ne pas
laisser ses affaires sans traitement
mais que la cellule en fait ça soit pas
explicitement dit qu'elle prend en
charge les questions de discrimination
d'homophobie de racisme ou autrees en
fait ça crée de la confusion y compris
auprès des associations puisque
certaines vous sollicitent sollicitent
en tout cas la plateforme signal sport
sur de sur des actes homophobes par
exemple elles obtiennent une réponse
mais sauf que en réalité l'information
n'est pas diffusée puisque normal
normalement la cellule signas sport ne
prend pas en charge les signalements en
lien avec des actes d'homophobie ou de
racisme donc le fait de ne pas clarifier
en fait ce que j'essaie de de de dire
c'est soit la la cellule signal sport ne
prend en charge que les VSS et dans ce
cas-là faut clairement les dicter et
donc faut indiquer y compris aux
associations qu'elle qu'elle ne signale
pas à Signal sport mais qu'elle passe
par d'autres instances pour que les
affaires soient traitées soit on décide
d'élargir le périmètre de la cellule et
dans ce cas-là on indique à tout le
monde qu'il qu'elle signale sur signal
sport mais l'entre deux manque de clarté
en réalité parce que si les associations
peuvent saisir mais qu'en réalité c'est
pas tout à fait le cas ça enfin moi je
trouve que du coup ça crée beaucoup de
confusion je comprends votre question
mais j'en ai la lecture plutôt inverse
c'est-à-dire que au contraire je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il est très clair qu'il y
a une priorité absolu donné au
traitement des violences sur signal
sport et que pour autant on fait quand
même notre travail qui est que si jamais
sur cette plateforme nous remonte des
cas de discrimination nous faisons en
sorte que ça puisse être traité par les
acteurs qui en ont la compétence à titre
principal donc on s'est mis dans un
système de et qui permet d'éviter un
vide total de prise en charge dans le
respect des
victimes alors j'entends ce que vous
comprenez ma question moi je comprends
votre réponse et je vous dis juste que
là on est dans vous avez commencé vos
propos en indiquant que vous vouliez
justement clarifier les rôles et les
missions de chacun à partir du moment où
on a la dilkra qui vient ici qui nous
explique qu'elles ont fait une demande
pour demander l'élargissement du
périmètre de la cellule que nous avons
des associations qui nous ont indiqué
qu'elles vous ont sollicité qu'elles ont
fait des signalements sur des actes
d'homophobie et que la cellule a répondu
mais que visiblement dans les textes
aujourd'hui la cellule n'est pas censée
prendre en charge les signalements euh
en lien avec des faits de racisme
d'homophobie ou de discrimination et
donc tout cela contribue à créer de la
confusion donc puisque l'objectif et
vous l'avez rappeler dans votre propos
liminaire et la clarification des rôles
et des missions de chacun en tout cas
nous on pense aujourd'hui que il faut
clarifier justement cette cellule signal
sport soit elle prend en charge toutes
les formes de enfin toutes les formes de
violence quelle qu'elle soit ou de de
racisme ou de discrimination
d'homophobie soit en fait elle se limite
aux violences et et je pense que ça
mériterait d'être clarifié justement et
le fait de dire il y a une priorité qui
est celle des violences mais pour pour
les associations qui seraient au courant
pour les associations qui connaissent
pour ceux qui sont informés d'aller
toquer à la porte de signal porte pour
obtenir des réponses pour moi ça manque
clairement de de clarté et donc enfin
voilà je là pour le coup je comprends
pas très bien je je pense que justement
parce que je suis attachée à la clarté
des rôles et des responsabilités je vous
dis et
j'assume que la priorité de signal sport
soit la lutte contre les violences
pourquoi parce que nos ennemis sont qui
là
l'omerta la
passivité la complaisance nous devons
donc mener des enquêtes avec toute la
diligence la fermeté
nécessaire quel est le sujet sur les
discriminations quel est le sujet c'est
que justement quand il y a des gestes
antisémites en tribune quand il y a des
cris de singe tout le monde l'entend
mais personne nagit en aval le sujet
c'est pas de révéler ces faits le sujet
c'est de les traiter c'est de les
éradiquer donc on saisit la justice on
saisit les commissions disciplinaires on
fait comme je le fais évoluer l'arsenal
législatif pour qu'il y ait des
interdictions judiciaires de stade et
que ces abrutis n'ai plus de place dans
nos
inintes le sujet il est fondamentalement
différent
fondamentalement alors moi je fais en
sorte oui quand il y a une victime qui
est perdue
elle soit pas laissée complètement sur
le bord de la route et donc je vais pas
dire que ça va être zéro traitement
parce que c'est pas le bon canal non on
prend en charge on remet dans les
circuits idouines le reste c'est
l'application s'agissant des lutte
contre les discriminations c'est
l'application des protocoles qui ont été
prévus c'est l'application des
interdictions judiciaires de stade c'est
la mise en œuvre des interdictions
administrativ de stade c'est la mise en
œuvre des interdictions commerciales de
stade c'est les réunions avec les
associations de supporters c'est les
réunions les ateliers de sensibilisation
avec les associations qui prennent en
charge les victimes c'est la désignation
partout de référents sur ces sujetsl
c'est des articles 40 quand c'est
nécessaire et à chaque fois avec la
dilcra dans les épisodes récents nous
les avons fait ces articles
40 et c'est aussi travailler sur
l'évolution culturelle pour l'inclusion
d' tout ce temps que j'ai investi
jusqu'au Qatar sur ces sujets là pour me
mobiliser personnellement pour dire
quand les choses étaient inacceptables
pour revrer à des tournois
inclusifs au cœur de la Coupe du monde
de
rugby pour organiser ces ateliers dédiés
une journée pleine le 17 mai
2023 sur ces sujets nous n'avons pas un
manque d'outil nous n'avons pas un
manque de levier nous avons besoin d'un
sursaut de se dire que ce qui est
intolérable ne doit pas faire seulement
l'objet d'une marche mais doit faire
l'objet d'une action systématique et
d'expliquer aux associations de
supporters que lorsqu'elles ont des
champs homophobes peut-être qu'elles ne
sont pas elles-mêmes homophobes mais ça
blesse profondément ceux qui sont en
face d'elle et que donc c'est pas
possible en 2023 c'est juste plus
possible donc on les retire ces mots on
les retire ces couplets on les retire
ses refrains et moi je les ai fait
bouger là aussi comme jamais personne
avant je les ai reçu deux soirées au
ministère des Sports pour leur parler
les écouter les comprendre avancer avec
eux alors nous avons des questions nos
collègues députés il y avait Stéphane
Mazard François piicmal peut-être
Stéphane vous commencez et François la
suite et peut-être par deux questions
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
madame la ministre pour vos propos
liminires et l'engagement qui est le
vôtre sur tous ces sujets je crois que
c'est quand même sal salué de de manière
assez
unanime moi je trouve que l'échange
était intéressant entre vous et et
Madame la rapporteur parce que on voit
bien que l'objectif il est le même c'est
améliorer notre
arsenal juridique notre capacité à
répondre et à prendre en compte donc les
les
remontter et
finalement on voit bien la ligne qui
doit qui doit soit nous faire basculer
vers vers signal sport c'est lorsqu
effectivement il y a une révélation qui
doit être faite et dans un milieu où
parfois il est très difficile
effectivement de libérer les paroles et
puis de l'autre côté il y a pas lieu à
révéler puisque tout cela se fait à la
vue de tout le monde
mais c'est vrai que nous dans le cadre
de ces travaux on s'aperçoit que
nonobstant le fait que ce soit fait aux
yeux de tout le monde et a la
connaissance de tous il y a assez peu de
réponses et vous avez indiqué madame la
ministre à plusieurs reprises avoir
rappelé les uns et les autres à leur
responsabilité en la matière mais force
de constater qu'encore il y a trop de de
trous dans la raquette alors est-ce qu'à
ce sujet vous avez des des pistes de
réflexion pour responsabiliser encore
plus avant les
acteurs exemple on nous a donné l'autre
jour cet exemple justement de de de
champ homophobe constater partout et
partout ça il suffisait d'être au stade
ou devant son écran ou ou ou ou écouter
la radio pour pour constater soi-même
ces champs homophobes et malgré ce pas
de suspension du match pas d'arrêt du
match et pas de responsabilité de ceux à
qui il appartenait de faire cesser ce
qui est un délit quand même donc voilà
alors comment on peut améliorer
améliorer les choses lorsque les faits
sont commis comme cela aux yeux et au vu
de tout le monde et et que les
responsables ceux qui sont en charge de
faire respecter la loi la loi du sport
la loi de notre
République ne ne ne s'exerce pas j'en
profite puisque j'ai j'ai la parole
madame la
ministre
sur sur une des propositions que nous
avons formulé avec Stéphane peu
lorsque nous nous lorsque nous avons
présenté à la commission des affaires
culturelles notre rapport sur l'impact
des Jeux Olympiques et paralympique
c'est la recommandation numéro 47 et ça
fait un peu écho tout à l'heure à ce que
vous disiez la loi la loi qui a
améliorer la démocratie la vie
démocratique de de de de nos fédérations
euh vous avez parlé aussi de la de la
proposition de loi de du sénateur plat
qui a été voté au au Sénat et nous nous
avons euh dans le casadre de nos travaux
donc fait la recommandation qui
consisterait à créer une autorité de
régulation et de contrôle qui serait une
sorte d'Aï donc une instance
indépendante sur le modèle de l'Agence
française de lutte contre le dopage et
qui serait doté de pouvoir de contrôle
et de sanction pour assurer l'éthique et
la transparence d' Leport alors on va
voir ce que vont donner les travaux qui
sont menés actuellement par le comité
coprésidé par par Marie-George Buffet
Stéphan Diagana mais est-ce que cette
idée d'avoir une une autorité
administrative indépendante qui
coifferait tous les comités l'éthiques
des fédérations avec un véritable
pouvoir de contrôle et et et de sanction
ça vous semble être une piste de
réflexion intéressante
merci peut-être que on enchaîne avec
François piicmal et puis madame la
ministre on répond pour les deux
questions en même temps s'il vous plaît
merci ouion bonjour madame la ministre
merci de de vos réponses bon euh je
crois que c'est un c'est un sujet qui
vous touche et je pense qu'il touche
tout le monde mais il est légitime à
l'issue de bientôt la fin de cette
commission d'enquête qu'elle est existé
parce que le nombre de témoignages qu'on
a eu de personnes qui ont été victimes
de violence de VSS de discrimination en
tout genre raciste homophobe et cetera
la légitime et il y a une véritable
omerta qui règne dans le dans ce pan de
la société que sont un certain nombre de
fédérations sportives et je mets pas
toutes les fédérations sportives dans le
lot il y en a qui sont plus vertueuses
que d'autres et il faut le dire aussi
simplement je vais prendre un exemple de
de comment des associations peuvent se
sentir
celés parfois on a eu on a fait la
projection récemment d'un d'une série
avec l'ancien footballeur wisem
belgassem qui a révélé son homosexualité
et qui n'a eu aucun aucun support on va
dire de la Fédération Française de foot
pour mener des
actions sur cette question là de grande
ampleur ce qui fait que c'est juste des
clubs qui l'ont contacté chacun de leur
côté mais de leur propre initiative ce
qui est quand même
révélateur du fait que oui on sait faire
des
actions LGBT washing comme on dit ou
antiracisme washing une fois de temps en
temps on a fait un atelier on on a fait
une démonstra tion médiatique ponctuelle
mais sur le fond c'est-à-dire le travail
de fond on est quand même très en retard
et lors de cette projection il y avait
une association qui s'appelle rouge
direct qui lutte contre l'homophobie
dans les stades et qui a qui nous a dit
qu'elle cessait ses activités après
avoir été harcelé notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux suite aux événements qui
ont eu lieu lors du
match entre Lyon et Marseille et cette
association a regretté que vous ne
l'urriez et pas apporter un soutien
public et moi je vous pose la
question pourquoi ne l'avez-vous pas
fait vous leur avez dit de de faire un
signalement Faros mais est-ce que le
combat et la symbolique et le ce que
vous représentez ne mérite
pas malgré toutes les la bonne volonté
que que
vous que vous dites que les engagements
soient plus forts et que un certain
nombre de personnes dans les fédérations
je vais le dire dire franchement on leur
rappelle certaines choses et qu'on
remette des points sur les i parce que
certains qu'on a pu auditionner euh
excusez-moi excusez-moi encore de
l'expression mais sont complètement à la
ramasse par rapport aux enjeux qu'il y a
aujourd'hui dans notre société sur les
discriminations et comment on fait pour
taper du point sur la table et remettre
desqu ce qui va pas dans un certain
nombre d'entre elles voilà je vous
remercie
alors
sur comment continuer à renforcer notre
action notre lutte contre ces actes
discriminatoires et notamment ces actes
homophobe monsieur le député
Mazar d'abord moi je demande
régulièrement le reporting
chiffré de ce que le sens sur ce
sujet ligne à ligne
202 sanctions prises par la Commission
de Discipline sur 175 matchs 106 rappels
à l'ordre 61 amendes avec surc 34
amandes ferme une fermeture de tribune
95 % de ces faits sanctionnés sont des
discriminations homophobes je tiens ce
reporting je leur demande
régulièrement y compris en pourcentage
de complétude c'est ça qui est
important
j'agis il y a des
y compris on la critique souvent y
compris par la FIFA et par l'UEFA qui
ont posé un certain nombre de règles de
protocole pour dire quand il y a des
paroles des chants des cris indécents en
tribune on interrom le match il y a un
speaker qui ramène les gens à la
dessence un premier appel à l'ordre le
match peut reprendre s'il y a un deuxème
acte à
nouveau app à l'ordre et ça peut même
s'arrêter dès ce moment-là trème rappel
à l'ordre fermeture définitive arrêt
définitif du match je l'ai dit lorsque
j'ai pris très fermement position
récemment à la suite du
match au PSG on s'en souvient tous un
funeste dimanche soir où ça a duré un
quart d'heure un quart
d'heure qu'est-ce que j'ai dit on
applique ces protocoles
combien de gens m'ont
rayonné combien de gens ont écrit à mon
cabinet pour dire mais elle se prend
attends
elle va nous apprendre la vie
là ces protocoles ils sont faits pour
être appliqué et quand j'ai passé du
temps avec les associations de
supporters que je les ai écouté que j'ai
compris aussi leur
perspective leur dilemme leur combat la
manière de réussir à atteindre des
objectifs qu'on par partage mais en le
faisant de manière intelligente pour que
ça passe pour que ce changement culturel
il se
produise c'est ça que j'ai construit
avec eux c'est dans ce respect ce
dialogue là aussi qu'on fait avancer les
choses et à l'assemblée générale de
l'association nationale du
supporteurisme ils m'ont écrit dans la
foulée plusieurs SMS des leaders de ces
formations pour me dire c'est la
première fois qu'on a enfin cette nature
d'échange
merci d'avoir fait bouger les
lignes alors je vais rien lâcher et oui
je vais continuer à faire remonter les
signalement sur la feuille de
match à faire ce que j'ai dit que je
ferais sur
l'impulsion dans les grandes fédérations
de commissions spécialement dédiées à
ces sujets-là comme la commission
antiiscrimination égalité de traitement
du Ruby la
cadette à prendre contact avec avec les
clubs à leur demander de prendre leur
responsabilité de désigner les référents
en charge de la lutte contre
l'homophobie dans chaque club à assumer
leur rôle en matière d'interdiction
commerciale de
stade alors on va continuer parce que
c'est pas possible et moi je me réjouis
oui
que il y a de jours il y a eu ce moment
entre un Kevin endoram qui avait été
idiot qui avait av été irrespectueux qui
avait été indécent dans ses propos il
est mené cet atelier il est été encadré
cette session d'entraînement avec les
Panam boys and girls à Paris qui l' fait
et qui est dit comme ça je me sens un
peu moins bête comme ça j'ai le
sentiment de réparer un peu de l'erreur
que j'ai commise et ils se rendent
compte parce qu'il y a ce dialogue parce
qu'il y a ce vivre ensemble aussi qui
vient c'est tout ça qu'on veut
poursuivre et j'en profite pour
enchaîner avec la question de rouge
direct je les ai reçu au ministère le 31
août j'étais heureuse de cet échange un
échange long un échange constructif un
échange où je leur ai demandé de
m'exposer leur
solution parmi les solutions clé ils
m'ont parlé des expériences qu'ils ont
analysé à l'étranger et ce parmi ces
solutions il y en a une qui a tout de
suite retenu toute mon attention c'était
de dire on va mettre des observateurs en
tribune parce que parfois il y a des
champs homophobes qui sont entonnés par
des gens depuis les
gradins et que le l'arbitre n'entend pas
parce qu'il est concentré il est sur son
terrain il est loin de ses tribunes et
là je l'UR dit mais évidemment
évidemment il faut qu'on fasse
progresser ça ça va complètement dans le
sens de ce que moi j'avais précédemment
demandé qui a une remontée sur la
feuille de match de tous ces incidents
pour qu'ils soit tracé
comptabilisé mais si on peut pas les
entendre
alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait donc là je me suis trouvé tout de
suite complètement aligné avec les
recommandations de rouge direct c'est le
point sur lequel mon combat est devenu
aussitôt commun au leur et j'ai pas fait
seulement que dire que c'était bien et
que c'était le sens de l'histoire à mon
sens j'ai tout de suite demandé à mon
cabinet d'enchaîner qui tout de suite a
pris contact avec les équipes à mess
avec les équipes à Saint-Étienne qui éta
les deux endroits parmi les quatre
recommandés par rouge
direct et nous avons enclenché le
travail en ce sens et je vais pas lâcher
là non plus on va le faire cette
remontée avec des observateurs
indépendants dans les tribunes qui vont
permettre de remonter à l'arbitre ou sur
la feuille de match quand l'arbitre n'a
pas entendu parce que c'était partial
parce que c'était furtif mais même quand
c'est furtif ça doit être
puni alors
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
dans les événements
récents sous prétexte que j'ai écrit une
lettre dans laquelle j'ai réussi
historique a embarqué le président de la
Fédée de foot le président de la ligue
de foot ma collègue aussi beréranger
Couillard on fait la pour la première
fois un courrier avec quatre signatures
pour exiger des dirigeants de club
qu'ils
agissent dans lequel on leur demande de
désigner des référents de faire arrêter
avec les assauts de supporter quand
c'est nécessaire c'est ch homophobe en
éliminant les paroles qui figurent et
oui ou là là qu'est-ce que j'ai eu le
malheur de dire dans cette lettre j'ai
eu le malheur de dire que des ateliers
de sensibilisation pouvaient être
utile mais ça l''est pas utile des
ateliers de sensibilisation quand on
voit ce que fait Johann l maire et fout
ensemble quand on voit la réaction de
Kevin endoram qui se dit mais évidemment
j'aurais dû faire ça déjà depuis
longtemps quand on voit les effets que
ça a sur le terrain c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est quoi ce qui m'est reproché
c'est d'avoir rajouté ce levier là en
plus du reste et soudainement on se met
à dire que je tiens pas mes engagements
mais c'est quoi moi je travaille avec
tout le monde et quand on est un
collectif on s'appelle d'ailleurs il
s'appelle d'ailleurs le collectif rouge
direct on divise pas on est là pour
additionner les forces de chacun
additionner les leviers parce que c'est
en additionnant ces leviers cette
mobilisation qu'on arrive à l'objectif
d'éradiquer de nos stades et de notre
sport c'est actes
discriminatoires donc pendant toute une
série de semaines ils se sont mis à dire
que je ne tenais pas mes engagements que
je ne faisais pas si que et et à me
dicter les modalités de mon action mais
moi je me laisse pas dicter les
modalités de mon action je les propose
je suis une femme politique je les mets
sur la table je les partage je les
éteille quand ils sont pas suffisants
j'écoute ce qu'on me dit et je complète
et derrière je fais ce que je
dis
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dès
qu'ils ont été victimes sur les réseaux
sociaux de ces attaques absolument
inadmissible dans l'heure qui a suivi je
répète dans l'heure qui a
suivi j'ai demandé à mon cabinet de les
contacter mon cabinet l'a fait dans les
heures qui ont suivi dans l'après-midi
qui a suivi ils ont été contactés pour
qu'on s'assure que ça allait à peu près
qu'ils étaient pas trop
traumatisés on leur a dit qu'il y avait
une façon de signaler ces événements
quand c'est du cyberhcèlement de ce type
qui était
phos ils nous ont dit que leurs avocats
étaient déjà sur cet élément-là
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire quand Faros
est saisi c'est l'équivalent en terme
d'effet vis-à-vis de la justice d'un
article 40 donc moi je n'avais pas
enclencher un article 40 et de toute
façon l'article 40 il n'est pas fait
pour qu'on exige d'une autorité publi
qu'elle devienne le témoin de certains
faits il y a la justice qui peut être
saisie comme ça je me suis assurée c'est
la première des choses que j'ai faites
que Pho a pu bien être saisi pour que
les voies pénales soient
activées alors moi j'ai été au côté de
rouge direct je le serai à nouveau à
l'avenir pour mettre en
œuvre les
recommandations qu'ils ont impulsé et
dans lesqueles je crois mais pour
continuer aussi les ateliers de
sensibilisation qui sont tout aussi
importants les attaques dont ils ont été
l'objet sur la sphère sociale sur les
réseaux sociaux sont inadmissibles et je
l'ai dit dans le tweet que j'ai fait en
suivant j'ai voulu indiquer dans ce
tweet que non je ne les avais pas laissé
tomber car c'était
inexact et j'ai évoqué Faros parce que
Faros permet la saisine de la justice
ils n'ont pas été laissés tomber et moi
je veux les appeler à la la persévérance
je veux qu'il continue je veux qu'il
soit comme l'ensemble des associations
qui ont décidé depuis des années de se
mobiliser qui ne cède pas au
découragement aucun d'entre nous ne doit
céder à ce
découragement en tout cas mon action
avec eux et avec les autres restera
pleine et
entière sur le sujet de la grande
autorité supra fédération et
cetera je comprends que la question se
pose
aujourd'hui avec l'expérience qui est la
mienne avec le recul qui est le mien
avec les situation de crise que j'ai eu
à gérer je pense que le meilleur service
à rendre aux fédérations c'est d'exiger
d'elles qu'elles aillent au bout de leur
responsabilité en matière
disciplinaire jusqu'au bout dans tous
les champs quand il y a des violences à
caractère sexiste et se on se contente
pas de licencier on se contente pas de
muter quelqu'un parce que ça ne fait que
déporter le problème ailleurs on va au
bout de la procédure disciplinaire en
lien avec l'administratif et le
judiciaire de la même dans la même
logique aujourd'hui on a des
dispositions qui depuis 2017 exigent des
présidents de fédération des
déclarations en matière de conflit
d'intérêt la loi du 2 mars 2022 est
venue renforcer cette obligation en
l'étendant au vice-président au trésori
au secrétaires généraux aujourd'hui je
les accompagne pour qu'il le fassent de
manière
effective on a autour de nous la loi
Sapin 2 on a autour de nous l'agence
française antiorruption on a autour de
nous la brigade de répression de la
délinquence économique de la délinquence
fiscale on a les audits financiers de
l'inspection générale de l'éducation du
sport et de la recherche de l'IGF sil
faut on a la Cour des comptes on a les
comités d'éthique on a la hatvp mais on
est bardé d'institutions qui aujourd'hui
se saisissent des sujets quand elles
sont
engagées donc faisons en sorte que
chacun prenne ses responsabilités tienne
toute sa place dans la chaîne avant
d'imaginer de créer à nouveau des
machins qui dilu et qui vont avoir pour
effet de retarder un certain nombre
d'actions de reporter sur d'autres de
diluer les responsabilités moi
aujourd'hui ça n'était pas forcément le
cas il y a quelques années quand il y
avait pas tout l'édifice que je viens
d'égrainer mais je pense aujourd'hui
qu'on a tout ce qu'il nous faut pour
qu'il y ait ce sursaut nécessaire dans
la vie fédérale et sans oublier et je le
redis sans oublier tous les endroits où
le métier est bien exercé où les
responsabilités sont bien embarquées où
les gens font avec
probité leur métier tiennent leur
responsabilité avec dessence avec
dévouement donc encore une fois je
comprends très bien que la question se
pose il y a eu trop de crisees pour
qu'il n'y ait pas le besoin d'évoquer
ces choses-là et je suis sûre que ça
fera partie des points abordés par
Marie-George Buffet Stéphan Diagana
comme ça fait partie des points qui sont
dans la copie avec les propositions du
CNOSF je comprends que cette question
soit dans l'atmosphère je pense
aujourd'hui pour reprendre mon point de
tout à l'heure que ça n'est pas la
priorité la priorité c'est de faire
jouer aux instances tous leur
rôle madame la ministre j'ai beaucoup de
questions dans la salle mais j'ai même
la rapporteur également qui a une
question pour vous et je passerai après
la parole au collègues députés
oui merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
peut-être ce qu'on va vous demander
madame la ministre dans la mesure du
possible de raccourcir vraiment les
réponses parce que il y a énormément de
questions je pense de la part des
collègues mais aussi pour la présidente
et
moi-même je vais peut-être commencer par
la fin du coup de votre intervention euh
pour indiquer peut-être ma surprise
parce que dans le cadre d'un rapport que
vous avez vous-même remis qui s'appelait
renovant le sport que vous avez remis à
Madame Laura Flessel il y avait une des
recommandations qui était de mettre en
place un contrôle de l'éthique externe
au mouvements sportifs donc ça veut dire
qu' a un moment vous avez estimé qu'il
était nécessaire d'avoir justement un
organe euh ou en tout cas un comité ou
un un dispositif qui permettrait
justement de faire ses contrôles et qui
serait peut-être extérieur donc première
question là-dessus la deuxième chose que
je je je voulais aussi faire remarquer
c'est que on a vous avez beaucoup parlé
de l'homophobie et le racisme dans les
stades moi je je tiens à le rappeler ici
ça n'a pas lieu que dans les stades
vraiment c'est important de le dire
parce que on parle effectivement de ce
qui se passe dans les stades où tout le
monde peut le voir en effet on peut être
témoin de ces champs homophobes ou de
ces actes ou de ces propos qui sont
tenus mais nous avons aussi aussi ici
même dans cette commission auditionneré
des personnes qui ont été victimes de
racisme je pense à un entraîneur de
rugby qu'on a à qui on a dit mangeur de
banane je pense à d'autres personnes qui
ont subi des des actes homophobes qui
n'étaient pas du tout dans le cadre du
stade et le fait je reviens je suis
désolé mais je suis un peu comme ça sur
la
clarification des outils qui sont mis à
disposition notamment des victimes
elles sont elles sont importantes et
elles sont importantes parce que je vais
vous lire un échange qu'on a eu dans le
cadre de ces audition puisque Eric
Arassus qu'on a pu auditionner ici euh
nous a dit que lui-même il avait signalé
donc des faits d'homophobie à la cellule
signal sport et qu'il a eu les réponses
la veille de son audition et on lui a
demandé euh comment ça se faisait qu'il
avait eu des réponses étant donné que ça
n'entrait pas dans le périmètre de
signal sport qui se limite aux violences
sexuelles et sexiste sa réponse est la
suivante c'est intéressant car on nous a
toujours dit que le sujet relevait de
signal sport je crois savoir que cette
cellule n'est aujourd'hui composée que
de de quatre personnes ce qui est peu
nous pensons qu'il faut mettre plus de
moyens si l'homophobie ne fait pas
partie de signal sport c'est intéressant
de l'apprendre aujourd'hui ce qui veut
dire que des associations qui
travaillent dans ce champ depuis de
nombreuses années n'étaient pas informé
que c'était pas dans le champ de signal
sport ils ont fait appel à la cellule
mais il n'en était pas informé et enfin
donc voilà c'est pour ça que pour moi je
pense qu'il est vraiment important mais
j'entends votre réponse depuis tout à
l'heure vous vous avait la même
là-dessus que c'est pas forcément la
direction que que ça prendrait en
peut-être un mot vous avez dit à
plusieurs reprises ces protocoles sont
faits pour être appliqués
euh vous êtes ministre des
Sports si ces protocoles sont faits pour
être appliqués moi je ma question elle
est logique c'est qui fait en sorte que
ces protocoles soient appliqués parce
qu'on a le sentiment depuis le début de
ces auditions en fait que personne ne
contrôle euh ce que font les ce que font
les fédérations et personne ne contrôle
si justement ces protocoles sont
appliqués madame la rapporteur alors sur
sur votre premier point c'est exact et
de mémoire c'était la recommandation 34
du rapport de rénovant le sport français
c'est exactement la raison pour laquelle
lorsque j'ai fait cette réponse au
député Mazar j'ai commencé par expliquer
que c'était comptenu de mon expérience
compte tenu du recul que j'avais pris et
de la gestion des crises que j'ai eu à
traverser dans les derniers mois j'ai
fait tous ces cavéates pour expliquer
que ma position sur le sujet avait mûri
d'autre part et je l'ai souligné
également dans cette réponse ma réponse
a aussi évolué parce que le droit
lui-même a évolué j'ai souhaité le
redire la loi Sapin 2 et sa mise en
œuvre le déploiement des contrôles de
LAFA dans un certain nombre de nos
fédérations du golf au foot en passant
par le tennis le renforcement des
obligations déontologiques et de
prévention des conflits d'intérêts dans
la loi du 2 mars 2022 tout ceci a avancé
dieu soit loué d'ailleurs heureusement
que les choses ont avancé donc on ne
peut pas aujourd'hui fin 2023 bientôt
2024 ne pas tenir compte de ce tout ce
que le législateur notamment c'est
échiné à mettre en place ce serait
irrespectueux de ma part de son travail
de ne pas en tenir compte
les choses ont bougé nous avons
aujourd'hui
l'arsenal pour veiller à ce que ces
situations ne se produisent
pas en matière de discrimination moi je
je je le je le
redis il y a l'application de ces
protocoles sous le contrôle de la Ligue
de foot professionnelle et de sa
commission de discipline connaissent ma
position sur le sujet j'ai des échanges
suivi avec eux en transparence avec les
associations nationales de supporters
dans le cadre de l'instance nationale du
supporteurisme que j'ai relancé élargi
renforcé
animé et la justice peut-être saisie
puisqu'il y a désormais non seulement la
reconnaissance que des propos homophobes
gravement discriminatoires sont un délit
mais en plus la faculté d'avoir une
peine complémentaire systématique de
interdiction judiciaire de stade pour 5
ans couplable à des interdictions
administratives sur le point que vous
avez évoqué que j'entends tout à fait
qui est de dire il y a pas que dans les
stades il y a aussi dans la vie
quotidienne des club vous avez
parfaitement raison et c'est la raison
pour laquelle le 30 janvier dernier j'ai
pris au côté de la première ministre un
engagement très important qui a consisté
à affirmer que désormais 100 % des
éducateurs sportifs serait formé à la
lutte contre le racisme l'antisémitisme
et les discriminations ce que ça veut
dire concrètement c'est l'intégration
d'un module obligatoire dans le cahier
des charges qui est imposé pour les
290 diplômes d'État dans le champ
jeunesse et sport et pour les 28000
stagiaires chaque année en formation
pour obtenir ce diplôme là donc c'est
pareil la mobilisation la
sensibilisation l'intégration au cœur
des responsabilités des acteurs du
système jusque dans la cellule de base
du sport français qui est le club bien
sûr et nous avançons en ce sens il faut
poursuivre alors peut-être que je vais
reprendre sur la partie éthique
puisqueon on l'a évoqué monsieur
L'Appartien semble indiquer que vous ne
faites pas preuve de suffisamment de
fermeté à l'égard des fédérations qui ne
respectent pas la loi je vais le citer
il est inacceptable que 17 % des
fédérations n'en ai pas je parle du
comité d'éthique alors qu'il s'agit
d'une obligation légale à cet égard je
trouve que les fédérations qui n'en ont
pas devait devrai être mis en demeure
sous peine de perdre leur délégation ne
plus être éligible au financement public
madame Bourdet a rappelé que l'animation
des comités d'éthique relève du CNOSF
donc je repose ma question la même que
sur les contrôles donc qui contrôle et
là en l'occurrence qui est responsable
de quoi puisque le CNOSF nous indique
que ça serait le ministère des Sports et
Madame Bouret ce matin nous dit que
c'est le
CNSF
madame la rapporteur dans la loi du 2
mars
2022 et je rends hommage certains des
députés ici présents qui l'ont porté est
affirmé haut et fort l'impératif pour
chacune des fédérations sportives de
notre pays de se doter d'un comité
d'éthique
aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble des
6 fédérations qui ont fait l'objet d'une
délégation en 2022 nous n'en avons plus
que deux
qui n'en ont pas mis en place un comité
d'éthique donc à David l'appartient je
réponds que nous ne sommes pas à 17 % de
carence dans ses fédérations dans son
mouvement sportif nous ne sommes plus
qu'à 2,3 % et les deux fédérations qui
sont encore en faute si je puis dire
sont les fédérations françaises de
ballon au point et de course camargaise
que j'invite avec beaucoup
de cœur
à mettre en place à leur tour leur
comité d'éthique ce sont les deux
dernières nous les attendons et j'espère
qu'elles pourront le faire
rapidement juste peut-être je veux une
précision est-ce que c'est la loi de
2017 ou 2022 sur les comités d'éthiques
parce que nous il nous semblait que
c'était
2017 pour moi c'est 2022 ce qu'avait
fait le législateur en 2017 c'était
d'imposer au titre de la hatvp des
déclarations de patrimoine et de
situation d'intérêt pour les présidents
des fédérations dispositif qui a
lui-même été étendu aux acteurs que j'ai
mentionné tout à l'heure les
vice-présidents les trésoriers les
secrétaires généraux par cette même loi
du 2 mars
2022 ok ben moi je suis sur le texte de
2017 et il y avait déjà les comités
d'éthiqu dans le texte donc alors c'est
peut-être ouais
l'obligation l'obligation a été affirmée
dans la loi de 2022 la création des
comités d'éthique heureusement est en
effet
antérieur une question de notre collègue
Céline
Calvez merci madame la présidente Madame
la rapporteur mes chers collègues madame
la ministre vous venez de citer
d'ailleurs la la loi du 2 mars 2022 vous
êtes revenu dans vos propos initiales
sur les avancé en terme de gouvernance
que ce soit la limite du nombre de
mandats sur la transparence sur la
vitalit démoc en faisant davantage
participer à la désignation des
instances dirigeantes il y a un point
sur lequel je voulais attirer votre
attention ça ne vous étonnera pas mais
j'aimerais bien revenir sur la parité la
parité il y a eu une l'instauration
d'une parité intégrale alors on peut se
dire que elle concerne le niveau
national qu'à partir de l'année
prochaine et le niveau infranational
qu'à partir de 2028 donc en fait on on
pourrait attendre mais c'est vrai qu'on
a beaucoup de défis concernant
l'instauration de cette parité si mes
souvenirs sont bons pour le niveau
infranational rien qu'au niveau régional
il aurait fallu trouver 3000 femmes
pouvant occuper les places dans les
instances dirigeantes euh pour rappel
notre attachement à ce titre 2 de la loi
du 2 mars 2022 c'était vraiment parce
que justement nous voulions mettre fin à
certaines homerta certains manque de
prise en considération de de de
problématique alors aujourd'hui ma
question est-ce que pour vous les
fédérations pour préparer ces échéances
de 2024 et de 2028 sur la parité se sont
mis en ordre de marche euh pour
améliorer ça et plus globalement est-ce
que il je voudrais vous donner
l'occasion euh peut-être de pouvoir
préciser ce qui en terme de gouvernance
là on vient de parler des comités
d'éthique mais ce que vous souhaiteriez
souligner aussi sur les avancées suite à
cette loi du 2 mars 2022 visant à
démocratiser le sport en France merci
beaucoup et j'enchaînerai sur une
deuxième question avec Monsieur Andy
carbra merci madame la Présidente merci
madame la ministre
pour le rappel du bilan positif que vous
faites mais nous sommes dans une
commission d'enquête une commission
d'enquête relevant des
dysfonctionnements
et je ne peux pas vous laisser dire que
vous souhaitez que rouge direct continue
son travail ils ont arrêté hier ils ont
annoncé la arê total de leurs travaux
suite aux menaces qu'ils ont subi suite
à un travail que nous nous appelons
lanceur d'alerte qu'on peut évidemment
chacun voir à l'ône de sa volonté mais
qui ont le mérite d'être les seuls dans
le paysage du monde associatif LGBT
d'avoir entraîné les toutes les
associations LGBT de France toutes les
associations de Centre LGBT et d'avoir
réussi à avoir ce travail délocalisé
régionalisé sur chacun des clubs parce
que c'est grâce à eux que le travail de
la prévention que le travail de la form
avec les clubs se font ce n'est pas né
que par une volonté politique c'est né
parce qu'il y avait les ressources et
sur ça on doit tous être content mais
cependant il y a quand même un
principe depuis février 1936 le Conseil
d'État nous explique que considérant
considérant que si même dans le cas où
les ministres re tiennent d'aucune
disposition législative un pouvoir
réglementaire il leur appartient comme à
tout chef de service de prendre les
mesures nécessaires au bon
fonctionnement de l'administration
placée sur leur autorité
l'homophobie est un crime ce n'est pas
un délit un propos homophobe est
sanctionné comme un
crime le les différents propos qui ont
peut être prononcés dans les stades et
en dehors des stades et merci à Madame
la rapporteur d'avoir pu le rappeler que
ça ne se passe pas que dans les stades
et que c'est un frein à l'inclusion pour
les personnes LGBTI dans pour rentrer
dans les clubs mais les propos ont été
par exemple pour Marseille ce champ
folklorique qui a quand même dit euh he
le patron de la Fédération Française du
du football il faut les tuer il faut les
tuer c'est ça le euh c'est C c'est
quand même ça le propos et la personne
qui
est
administrativement au-dessus de la FFF
et c'est pour ça que rouge direct
a plus ou moins pris des distances mais
c'est vous madame la ministre vous êtes
la patronne des
fédérations
maintenant nous sommes face à la
disparition de l'association lanceurs
d'alerte qui faisait ce travail d'alerte
et eux-mêmes le reconnaissent d'avoir
été capable de travailler avec vous je
vous contredis juste et ça peut-être que
vous Prz apporter des précisions la
proposition de rouge direct concernant
la lutte de dans l'homophobie de
l'homophobie dans les stades c'est une
composition tripartite d'observateur
observateur venant du monde des centres
LGBT du service d'ordre des clubs et
j'ai oublié la trème partie excusez-moi
mais vous devez vous en souvenir mieux
que moi et c'était d'ailleurs sur cette
idée là que vous étiez positionné ou du
moins que rou direct l'avait prise
d'ailleurs j'espère que
l'expérimentation va pouvoir quand même
aller jusqu'au bout et mener son ce
travail qui est essentiel mais dans ce
côté tripartite de côté collégial si je
peux dire mais il y a une question au
bout d'un moment quand on a aussi alors
excusez-moi mais le patron de la FP qui
dit que la sanction contre les actes
homophobes dans les stades et
inefficace contredisant vos propres
propos madame la ministre vu que vous
n'êtes pas contre la sanction et bien il
faut peut-être rappeler à l'ordre et
faire respecter le droit et je le
rappelle l'homophobie et tous les
racismes et le racisme de manière
générale n'est pas un délit c'est du
pénal c'est un délit alors euh peut-être
je je je rebondis moi j'ai toute
confiance dans les dirigeants de de
rouge direct pour qu'il prennent les
décisions qu'ils pensent approprié ce
que j'ai voulu indiquer c'est que leur
cause et je l'avais dit dans mon dernier
tweet est noble on a besoin dans notre
pays que les associations qui sont en
charge aujourd'hui qui ont choisi de
faire sienne la cause de la lutte contre
toutes les formes de discrimination
poursuive et évidemment
ce message s'adresse à l'ensemble
d'entre elles à foot ensemble à oval
citoyen au coque festif à Panam boys à
SOS Homophobie tous font un travail et
dans cette fameuse lettre qui m'a été
reprochée par rou direct je soulligne
que leur action est utile et nécessaire
alors je vais revenir à ces deux
occurrences qui ont été ces deux matchs
celui à au g contre l'OM et celui entre
Montpellier et
Rennes vous m'avez fait une grande
tirade sur le fait que je devais prendre
mes responsabilités mais qu'est-ce qu'on
a fait avec Olivier avec Olivier clin on
les a écrits les deux articles
40 dès le lendemain
matin un petit échange avec lui hop
direct on agit action
réaction et on le fera aussi souvent que
nécessaire
et heureusement que je n'ai pas
entendu la LFP dire que les sanctions
étaient inefficaces que c'est nié son
propre rôle je ne crois pas qu'ils aient
eu l'outre cuuidance ou la bêtise de
dire ça ça leur ressemble pas tellement
je pense qu'au contraire ils ont
conscience que l'un des pouvoirs qu'ils
doivent exercer est évidemment ce
pouvoir
disciplinaire
alors s'agissant du thème plus on va
dire plus positif de la féminisation et
du mouvement qui est en train de
s'opérer en faveur de la féminisation
des instances dirigeantes du sport
français la loi de 2022 pose un principe
de parité au niveau des instances
nationales à
2024 et à 2028 à l'échelon régional sur
2024 et là aussi ça fait partie des
indicateurs que je suis comme le lait
sur le feu on a besoin d'avoir 400
femmes pour être au rendez-vous de cela
sur ces 4 100 femmes une première
fournée de 150 femmes a été identifiée
et formé par le
CNOSF une seconde promotion de 150
femmes est en train d'être formée leur
cycle de formation s'achèvera en
septembre 2024 au lendemain des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques il restera
encore un volant de 100 femmes à aller
identifier dans les territoire et à
former pour le début de 2025 date de
renouvellement des instances des
fédértion
et s'agissant de l'échelon régional
c'est plus encore que 3000 c'est 3600
femmes qui doivent être trouvées elles
ont commencé à l'être dans un certain
nombre de fédérations d'autres ont
besoin d'accélérer et mon souhait le
plus cher est évidemment que les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques le mouvement
de grande cause nationale en 2024 donne
envie à un nombre plus important de
femmes de jeunes de rejoindre les rangs
de nos bénévoles je rappelle que le
sport est le premier secteur
d'engagement en France aujourd'hui et je
pense que les perspectives réjouissantes
qui sont les ntres sur ces plans-là
permettront de continuer à être au
premier plan en la
matière alors euh merci pour pour ces
réponses du coup ça m'a permis d'aller
vérifier les textes de loi comme ça on
va pouvoir tous être au carré sur les
comités d'éthique donc je reprends la
loi de 2017 a mis en place
l'obligation d'avoir les comités
d'éthique donc en 2017 ce qui a apporté
la loi de 2022 c'est le fait qu'il soit
indépendant donc je comme ça tout le
monde est au carré sur les comités
d'éthique c'est pour ça qu'on a posé
plusieurs fois la question parce qu'il
nous semblait euh assez illogique en
réalité que depuis 2017 on est encore
des fédérations qui n'est toujours pas
de comité d'éthique même si vous nous
dites aujourd'hui qu'il en reste plus
que deux 2017- 2023 ça fait 6 ans c'est
un peu long pour mettre en place un
comité d'éthique pour une fédération
quand c'est obligatoire donc voilà juste
comme ça tout le monde est et est sur la
même sur les sur les mêmes textes de loi
c'est important puisque on écrit la loi
ici
euh moi je voudrais revenir sur les
différentes auditions qu'on a eu
l'occasion de faire dans le cadre de
cette commission nous avons auditionné
de très nombreux présidents DTN
directeurs généraux de
fédération la très grande majorité
d'entre eux je dis pas tous mais la très
grande majorité a fait preuve au mieux
d'une totale méconnaissance des
dispositifs mis en place au sein de leur
fédération pour lutter contre les VSS
que ce soit l'homophobie les
discriminations au pire d'inexactitude
voire de par jure parfois devant cette
commission d'enquête comment est-ce que
vous n l'expliquez alors que votre
prédécesseuse madame Marie signanou a
fait desvss une action majeure de son
mandat de ministre et que la directrice
des sports actuel madame BOURD est l'une
des spécialistes reconnus de ces
questions et qu'elle dirige un corps la
cellule ministérielle relative à la
lutte contre les les violences sexuelles
dans le
sport je pense que certains ont montré
qu'ils étaient au fait de ces procédures
encore ce matin
h je crois qu'il faut pas caricaturer il
y a eu en effet certaines
auditions décevante pour ne pas dire
catastrophique qui montre que on a
besoin
d'élever absolument le niveau
d'implication au plus haut niveau de ces
fédérations sur ces sujets de violence à
caractère sexiste et sexuel et je veux
simplement ajouter peut-être que la
seule chose qui est potentiellement
rassurante par rapport à cela c'est de
se dire que en dessous les équipes dont
c'est le métier à temps plein elles sont
bien offert fait de tout cela et je
rappelle que nous avons mis en place
dans toutes les fédérations et dans tous
les établissements publics du ministère
des référents spécialisés sur ces
questions et je rappelle que la loi du 2
mars 2022 a eu aussi pour effet non
seulement d'affirmer donc l'indépendance
des comités d'éthique mais également de
prévoir la
formation au sujet de la lutte contre
les VSS de l'ensemble des
éducateurs donc voilà il faut continuer
à faire œuvre de
pédagogie et je pense que votre
commission d'enquête aura fait œuvre
profondément utile en la
matière alors je pense vraiment vu quand
même maintenant que ça fait plusieurs
mois qu'on travaille dans le cadre de
cette commission d'enquête qu'il n'y a
personne ici qui a pour volonté de
caricaturer les différentes audition
qu'on a pu avoir ici mais faut quand
même avouer que quand on a des
dirigeants de fédération qui ne
connaissent pas les dispositifs qui
mettent plusieurs mois pour faire un
déclenchement ou un signalement
d'article 40 qui ne vérifi pas que les
que les articles 40 ont été déclenchés
qui qui parfois ne signalent pas ne font
pas remonter ne prennent pas au sérieux
ne déclenche même pas d'enquête
lorsqu'ils ont connaissance de fait donc
je pense qu'on est quand même loin de la
caricature quand on évoque le fait que
il y a de graves dysfonctionnement en
tout cas dans certaines fédérations moi
je suis assez étonné en fait de vous
entendre prendre ça de manière
totalement inversée parce que oui il y a
des fédérations qui font très bien leur
boulot j'ai presque envie de dire et qui
prennent au sérieux ces question mais
vous avez depuis le début de votre
propos vous nous avez indiqué que vous
ne vouliez rien lâcher que vous seriez
intraitable avec tout ce qui
dysfonctionne nous on porte à votre
recnaissance et vous avez pu les voir
ces auditions différents
dysfonctionnements et je trouve pour le
coup que si vous considérez que nous on
est plutôt dans la caricature je trouve
pour le coup de que que de votre côté
peut-être vous minimisez les
dysfonctionnements auquels on a pu faire
face dans le cadre de ces différentes
auditions donc en fait moi ce que je
demande c'est très simple c'est il y a
plusieurs fédérations avec les qu'on a
pu entendre ici
euh qui ont qui ont voilà où les
auditions ont été pour certaines d'entre
elles vraiment catastrophiques et
extrêmement inquiétantes et donc moi ma
question c'est quels sont les leviers de
votre ministère pour y remédier
alors madame la rapporteur puisque vous
aimez être précise en droit je revient
sur notre débat sur les comités
d'éthique pour redire qu'en 2017 ça
n'était pas des comités d'éthique qui
ont été institués mais des comités doté
d'un pouvoir d'appréciation sur un
ensemble de matières et que c'est bien
l'article 39 de la loi du 2 mars 2022
qui a institué le principe l'obligation
de ces comités d'éthique et demander
leur
dépendance sur le plan que vous évoquez
jamais je n'ai prononcé le mot
caricature non non non alors pardon si
je l'ai fait j'ai j'ai dit quoi sur
caricature non j'ai j'ai dit j'ai dit
j'ai dit il ne faut pas caricaturer je
n'ai pas dit que la commission d'enquête
avait avait
caricaturé non je pense que dans les
auditions et
j'ai l'intégralité
des auditions retranscrites j'ai lu 96 %
d'entre elles donc je je je me fait ma
propre opinion sur qui a été imprécis
qui a été au contraire excellent qui a
été probant qui a été démonstratif et
cetera maintenant si le point est de
dire qu'il y a besoin de continuer
laournamento culturel la transformation
culturelle du monde des fédérations la
réponse est oui je pense qu'on serait
pas en emble dans cette salle si on n
partageait pas la
conviction c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai dit qu'il fallait marteler
l'obligation de signalement que la PPL
plat était une bonne chose parce qu'elle
la consacré sur le plan législatif
s'agissant de l'obligation de
signalement aux autorités
administratives j'ai évoqué le contrôle
d'honorabilité j'ai dit à quel point il
fallait encore le faire monter en
puissance embarquer toutes les
fédérations dedans faire en sorte qu'il
n'y en ait plus qui soi dans des
stratégies de contournement à par
exemple prétendre que avec une licence
dirigeant on échappe au fourche Codine
du contrôle
d'honorabilité je suis la première à
leur dire que quand on est avec des
bénévoles sur le bord de terrain qui
sont en contact régulier avec des
mineurs il est essentiel d'essayer de
licencier ces personnes-là d'émettre une
licence pour qu'elles puissent être dans
le champ du contrôle
d'honorabilité je veux aussi qu'il y ait
des professions par exemple cell dit de
recruteurs bénévoles y compris dans le
foot qui aujourd'hui sont des zones
grises des zones de non droit où il y a
pas de formation où il y a pas
d'exigence en terme réglementair que
tout ceci soit normalisé pour qu'on
arrive maintenant qu'on l'a mis en place
ce système d'information et de contrôle
de l'honorabilité et ben qu' puisse
embarquer le plus large nombre possible
d'acteurs pour que cette action de
prévention elle soit la plus efficace
possible donc là-dessus je je je peux
pas être plus allié de vos conclusions
et je peux pas faire plus que de
souligner l'ensemble de ces élémentsl de
la même façon quand je dis qu'il faut
que les fédérations aillent au bout de
l'exercice de leur pouvoir disciplinaire
moi j'ai même envie que dans les cas les
plus graves des violeurs des
multirécidivistes
il y a plus du tout de faculté d'émettre
une licence même si on dit que ça
ressort de la liberté individuelle et
qu'il faut qu'un individu qui a purgé sa
peine puisse voilà faire du sport dans
un club de sport bah moi pas
tellement moi pas
tellement alors une question de notre
collègue Stéphane Buchou et nous
pourrons enchaîner avec belkir badade
s'il vous
plaît merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre moi je vais démarrer mon
propos en en vraiment saluant les propos
que vous avez tenu dans dans dans votre
intervention liminaire votre votre
engagement et et votre détermination à
lutter pied à pied contre
entre autres les
VSS cette commission d'enquête elle a
été mise en elle a été créée pour euh
mettre en en en lumière identifier euh
les dysfonctionnements des fédérations
sportives je je vais
euh peut-être prolonger les propos de
Madame la rapporteur c'est vrai que et
je sais que vous avez enfin j'imagine
dans tous les cas que vous avez pu
prendre connaissance des auditions qui
ont été qui ont été menées en
particulier de la part de certains
responsables de fédération française de
sport et et et pas les moins puissantes
et effectivement je je je veux ici
témoigner que nous nous avons très
régulièrement eu à faire
face je je vais dire le terme à une
forme
d'irresponsabilité les uns les autres se
rejetant la faute sur au final ceux qui
étaient absents de l'audition j'ai j'ai
eu l'occasion de le Red dire encore une
fois ce
matin donc voilà moi je voulais je
voulais dire cela parce que ça dit ça
dit quelque
chose de la situation ça dit quelque
chose du monde sportif et euh dit
autrement moi je souhaite vivement que
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs et je partage ça avec vous
cette commission elle fait œuvre utile
elle termine ses travaux en tous les cas
en termes d'audition aujourd'hui et et
et et j'espère qu'elle va permettre la
semaine prochaine chers collègues pardon
madame la Présidente excusez-moi je je
imp ça a juste été prolongé pardon d'une
semaine euh merci
Belk non mais j'espère j'espère vraiment
que que et c'est c'est ma première
question que vous allez en tirer des
enseignements parce que ça a démontré
également que les liens entre le
ministère évidemment pas que depuis pas
que depuis que vous avez été nommé mais
les liens entre le ministère et
certaines fédérations ont besoin d'être
peut-être retissé parce que vous avez
dit aussi les mots tout à l'heure dans
dans votre propos liminaire il y a une
forme d'omerta il y a une forme
d'impunité chez un certain nombre de de
dirigeants qui où nous disent qu'ils ne
sont absolument pas au courant de ce qui
a pu se passer pendant des décennies au
sein de au sein de leur fédération et
pour vous dire là aussi mon sentiment
moi je je je ne vois pas bien comment
malgré tout ce que tout ce que vous nous
avez dit et que vous avez mis en œuvre
et votre encore une fois votre
engagement et votre détermination
comment
euh les choses vont pouvoir changer et
et ce changement de braquet impérieux et
nécessaire va pouvoir se mettre en place
donc j'aurais voulu vous entendre par
rapport à ça et puis ma ma deuxième
question
elle est née de l'audition de ce matin
du président et du directeur de la
Fédération française de judo qui qui
nous ont indiqué avoir euh 180
signalements de 10F 180 signalements VSS
homophobie racisme et cetera
euh et sur ces 180 95 signalements de
VSS
95 dossiers qui à minima enfin qui
implique un certain nombre de de de de
personnes alors sans être trop
schématique on va dire 95 personnes et
quand on pose la question et c'est cette
questionlà que je leur ai posé entre
autres de savoir s'il savait ce qu'il
était advenu de de ces 95 personnes qui
sont des éducateurs des
encadrants et bien ils ne savent pas
répondre et donc c'est aussi ça que je
que je voulais porter à votre
connaissance parce que là on est
vraiment dans une forme
d'incompréhension on a des personnes qui
qui sont auteurs de faits
grave depuis et c'est fait date d' y a
quelques années et on ne sait pas nous
dire si ces gens-là exercent encore des
fonctions dans le monde du judo
puisqu'il s'agit du judo ou dans
d'autres fédérations et madame la
ministre que peut-on faire pour faire en
sorte que ces situations n'existent plus
merci
beaucoup belkir peut-être
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre beaucoup de choses ont été euh
dites et je rejoins les propos de
Stéphane bchau sur les relations les
relations entre le ministère des Sports
et les fédérations
euh je pense que c'est important euh
qu'il y ait notamment à l'ône de
l'organisation des des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques et nous l'espérons tous
de beaucoup d'autres grands événements à
à venir un lien beaucoup beaucoup plus
fort je sais pour avoir travaillé avec
de nom nombreus de ces fédérations en
tant qu'élu local pendant de nombreuses
années que c'est pas forcément facile
tous les tous les jours euh moi je
voudrais évoquer avec vous alors je
voudrais d'abord vous remercier pour les
les propos plutôt clairs que vous avez
indiqué tout à l'heure concernant rouge
direct c'était une de mes interrogations
hein voilà merci de de l'éclairage que
vous avez pu apporter je voudrais
évoquer avec vous plutôt la question du
racisme qui est un véritable fléo
beaucoup parl ement de la lutte contre
l'homophobie euh il y a une véritable
chape de plomb je sais de quoi je parle
quand je dis ça et le gouvernement a
activé l'article 40 de la procédure
pénale sur ce qui est arrivé à yangange
il il y a quelques jours euh mais
derrière il y a un belkir beladad
beaucoup d'autres et moi je l'ai vu en
tant qu'adjoint au sport il y a
effectivement un engagement très fort du
gouvernement depuis plus plusieurs
années sur la lutte
contre toute forme de radicalisation
dans les clubs et j'ai pu moi-même le
constater et prendre les mesures
nécessaires quand il fallait le prendre
et j'avais pas besoin forcément de
l'État à ce moment-là pour le faire
euh pour revenir au racisme c'est un
véritable fléo nous avons
aujourd'hui une diffusion de la haine
partout dans notre société euh dans
beaucoup de nos structures y compris in
de l'éducation nationale j'tais organisé
très récemment une une réunion publique
où ça m'a été rapporté de la part de
plusieurs syndicats ou représentants
représentants d'élèves le le monde du
sport n'y échappe pas parce que c'est un
fait social majeur dans notre dans notre
pays vous
avez autre combat et celui aussi de
lutter contre ces prêcheurs de haine et
il se trouve également aujourd'hui et de
plus en plus dans les clubs sportif vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure votre volonté
euh de vous y attaquer avec déjà des
mesures notamment la formation des
éducateurs et je pense que ça passe par
là euh mais est-ce qu'il y a euh je je
pense qu'on arrive beaucoup mieux à à à
identifier encore une fois on revient à
la question du de de l'identification et
et et de la mesure de et de l'ampleur de
phénomène j'ai le sentiment d'après tous
les moyens tous les témoignages que que
que ce soit au sein de de de cette
commission d'enquête euh ou de
l'expérience qui est la mienne euh
d'avoir énormément de de de retours mais
on ne sait pas les mesurer
suffisamment aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y
a d'autres mesures qui que vous entendez
prendre au-delà des de la mesure que
vous avez indiqué tout à l'heure sur la
formation absolument nécessaire de nos
éducateurs et et de tous les bénévoles
et et dirigeants je vous
remercie
madame la ministre c'est à VOUS
ouais je pense
que par rapport au au remarque député
bchau je pense que il y a un autre
aspect qui est essentiel dans
l'évolution que j'ai apporté à la
Direction des Sports autour du
renforcement du dialogue de gestion avec
les
fédérations aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup
de documents qui sont requis des
fédérations projet sportif fédéral
projet pluriannuel de performance les
documents qui déclinent les principes
essentiels de la République tout un tas
de choses qui sont
écrites ce qu'il faut c'est un dialogue
serré exigeant précis assis sur des
indicateurs de
performance sur des
chiffres pour s'assurer que à partir
d'une matrice des risques d'une
cartographie où on se dit tel féd c'est
plutôt ce problème là c'est plutôt cette
vulnérabilité c'est plutôt ce risque ou
c'est plutôt cette historique qu'il faut
essayer de réparer qu'il y ait cette
vision exigeante et qu'on manie aussi
des éléments avec l'Agence nationale du
sport qui peuvent consister parfois à
revenir sur l'attribution de certaines
subvention on a des cordes de
rappel
avant d'aller au bazooka du retrait de
la délégation qui est une punition
collective pour tout le monde il y a
différents moyens qui nous permettent de
nous assurer que chacun fait son boulot
et le fait bien moi c'est cette culture
là que je veux inscrire au cœur de la
Direction des Sports quand je suis
arrivé beaucoup d'entre eux beaucoup des
agents de mon ministère étai un peu
triste un peu abattu parce qu'ils
avaient perdu un certain nombre
d'attributions au profit de l'Agence
nationale du sport mais je leur ai dit
mais c'est une opportunité de faire bien
mieux votre boulot en matière régalienne
là où le cœur de l'État est attendu
c'est une occasion rêvé de vous inscrire
dans le renforcement de ce dialogue de
gestion et dans l'évaluation du travail
mené par les opérateurs c'est ça qu'on
va faire
ensemble et moi je vais me battre pour
que vous ayez des effectifs renforcés
pour que ce régalien vous ayez la
capacité à bien le faire et aujourd'hui
l'inspection générale je la sollicite
très fortement elle vous l'a dit plus
fortement que jamais 16 audits depuis
que je suis arrivé le 20 mai 10 dans le
cadre des contrôles récurrents 6 à
Doc sans compter le nombre de cisines
parquet financier article 40 et cetera
moi j'active le système pour que
chacun aille au bout et s'il faut je
l'ai dit dans mon propos liminaire s'il
faut renforcer encore un peu les choses
en matière de corde de
rappel moi je suis avec vous là-dessus
s'il faut inventer une forme allez je
vais prononcer le gros mot une forme
d'impeachment de fédération de président
de fédération qui partirait sur des
sentiers totalement
inacceptables pour être sûr qu'on a pas
attendre 3 mois pour obtenir une finé
une démission mais d'aller plus vite
dans les cas les plus graves et dans les
cas de blocage des institutions parce
que d'abord et avant tout c'est les
instances qui doivent jouer leur rôle
mais si pour X et Y raison elles ne le
font pas oui peut-être qu'il faut tenter
ces ultimes cordes de rappel et si ça
doit faire partie des éléments de
fortification de notre modèle sportif
faisons-le le général de Gaulle a eu le
génie d'inventer ce
système il a dit je veux un état qui
tient tout son rôle et je veux en même
temps une autonomie du mouvement sportif
il a pas dit
l'indépendance et ça je me suis fait le
plaisir de le rappeler en temps utiles à
la FIFA quand il venait donner des
leçons parce que je grattais d'un peu
trop près Noël
lerette qui a écrit que les fédérations
étaient indépendantes personne les
fédérations sont autonomes elles sont
délégataires d'un service public dont le
titulaire est l'État devant le contrôle
des Français et de la représentation
nationale ce système
d'équilibre il est assez
génial et il faut qu'il marche il faut
qu'il continue à marcher et il a plein
de réussites je les ai évoqué tout à
l'heure y compris en terme de
performance sportive où notre pays on
l'ignore trop souvent on le dit pas
assez et peut-être l'une des toutes
toutes toutes meilleur nation si ce
n'est la meilleure nation sportive au
monde en terme de
sporco maintenant ce qu'il faut c'est
que ceux qui trahissent le système ceux
qui font pas leur
boulot et ben on les empêche de
continuer en allant les chercher par les
bretelles et en activant tout ce que le
législateur tout ce que vous avez mis
entre nos mains et tout ce que notre
République compte d'organes indépendant
de cours d'expertise d'inspection
d'audit pour nous permettre de faire
ça et tout ce que vient de dire vaut
exactement pour la lutte contre le
racisme et là moi j'ai envie de dire
j'ai envie même d'aller plus loin une
des raisons pour
lesquelles je
je je me bats sur ces sujets avec vous
sur le fait d'arriver à libérer le sport
de ces
mots c'est parce que je pense que le
sport fait partie de ces quelques
ingrédients qui peuvent rendre la
société meilleure plus sol solidaire
plus
fraternel et que en soi la pratique d'un
sport à forceerie d'équipe dans un club
c'est l'apprentissage de la mixité de
l'inclusion du partage du vivre ensemble
dans une France bigarée c'est ça le
sport c'est pour ça que c'est important
et c'est pour ça que parfois je me suis
agacée en disant le sujet c'est pas
balance ton sport c'est pas ça le sujet
c'est de balancer ceux qui détruisent le
sport ceux qui le salisse ce qui l'abîme
parce que le sport lui fait partie des
solutions pour notre
société c'est la chance avec les jeux
c'est la chance avec la grande cause et
on va essayer tous ensemble d'être au
rendez-vous euh alors moi je vais
peut-être rebondir sur ce qui a été
indiqué notamment sur la question des
indicateurs pour pouvoir faire le suivi
avec les fédérations et euh puisqu'on a
eu l'occasion de d'auditionner les
représentants de la Cour des comptes qui
ont jugé à juste titre ces documents
trop généraux et ne tenons pas
suffisamment compte des situation
spécifique des fédérations donc on est
bien loin de justement de ces
indicateurs précis qui permettraient
d'identifier quel problème sur quelle
fédération et quelle solution y apporter
dans la même veine madame BOURD nous a
indiqué qu'il n'était pas exclus de ne
pas renouveler la délégation accortée à
certaines fédérations qui ne respectent
pas leurs obligations donc est-ce que
vous nous le confirmez visiblement il y
a déjà quelques fédérations qui qui ont
été identifiées pour le renouvellement
de leur
délégation en 2024 fin 2024 et enfin
lorsqu'on l'a interrogé sur le caractère
très vague et peu prescriptif des
contrats qui ont été signés en mars 2022
madame bourndet a reconnu qu'ils ont été
rédigés dans l'urgence et constituent un
premier g c'est d'autant plus
regrettable que l'imprécision des
obligations et objectifs qui figurent
dans ces contrats peut fragiliser
juridiquement une décision de retraite
délégation donc tout ça nous il nous
semble justement comme vous l'évoquez si
on veut pouvoir suivre
efficacement le le travail de ces
fédérations il faut des indicateurs
précis or il semble qu'aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le cas puisque c'est ce que
dit la Cour des comptes et c'est ce qu'a
reconnu la directrice des sports et
comme vous avez évoqué la question des
dirigeants des fédérations justement
est-ce qu'il ne faudrait pas inscrire
dans les contrats de délégation des
clauses relatives à l'obligation
d'intégrité et d'exemplarité des
dirigeants ce qui permettrait d'aller
dans le sens de ce que vous avez
proposer concernant le fait de pouvoir
parfois et bien oui avoir des dirigeants
de
fédération qui doivent partir parce
qu'il ne comme certains parce que il y a
des problèmes en lien avec leur
comportement alors moi j'ai j'ai j'ai
une culture je viens de la Cour des
comptes très
quantitative et je peux vous dire que je
regorge de dossiers bourré de
chiffres et mes équipes le
savent deux membres sont dans cette
pièce dès que je manque d'un
chiffre je le réclame jusqu'à
l'obtenir donc de me dire que dans le
sport français il y a pas assez
d'indicateurs pardon mais
non il y en a partout et beaucoup sont
d'ailleurs publqus y compris dans des
publications comme ça services de
référence de nos ministères je pense par
exemple à
l'INJEP donc tout ce qu'on veut
documenter établir factualiser on le
peut ensuite vient la question de la
volonté d'où ce que j'ai dit sur le
dialogue de gestion et d'où la démarche
que j'ai demandé à la directrice des
forces d'impulser qui est que au terme
de chacun des rendez-vous de dialogue de
gestion il y ait un courrier qui soit
écrit au Président ou à la présidente de
la Fédération pour maté réaliser les
points de progrès qui ont été
identifiés je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
les projets sportifs fédéraux les
projets pluriannuel de performance les
documents sur l'éthique et l'intégrité
en application du contrat d'engagement
républicain les
audits tout ceci il y a plor de
documents on va pas produire encore plus
d'usine à papier il faut que on prenne
dans ces
documents tout ce qui éteille des
dysfonctionnements et là qu'on lâche
plus
l'affaire avec cette cartographie des
risques savoir sur quelle fédération on
a besoin de mettre l'accent sur quoi et
ensuite on le suit dans le temps c'est
le sens des audits permanents de
l'igsr et des audits ponctuels que j'ai
été amené à lancer ou parfois à relancer
dans certaines fédérations vous savez à
quoi je fais
référence
nos fédérations aujourd'hui
elles savent exactement ce qu'elles ont
à faire elles ont à réussir une triple
mission former des champions développer
la pratique
être exemplaire en matière d'éthique et
d'intégrité et dans l'éthique et
l'intégrité elles connaissent très bien
les sous-rubriques que nous avons balayé
ensemble les violences à caractère
sexiste et sexuel les maltraitances le
racisme l'antisémitisme les
discrimination antil LGBT le dopage la
manipulation des parils
sportifs tout ça est parfaitement clair
et pour avoir été au cœur d'une
fédération je peux vous dire que quand
on veut traiter un sujet quand on veut
l'emmener là où le législateur nous a
mis l'ambition qu'il soit on a
absolument tous les levier pour le
faire concernant c'est c'est contrat de
délégation bon déjà visiblement vous la
Cour des comptes n'est pas d'accord
puisque eux justement ils indiquent dans
leur rapport que les indicateurs ne sont
pas précis euh sur la manière dont
s'effectuent les contrôles est-ce qu'on
est sur du déclaratif du contrôle sur
pièce euh comment ça se passe et juste
une question puceque vous avez évoqué
l'igesr dans le cadre de de de la revue
permanente donc l'igusr est censé
contrôler régulièrement l'ensemble des
fédérations or il nous est apparu que
certaines fédérations n'avaient pas fait
l'objet de contrôle depuis de nombreuses
années comme la fédération de hand dont
le dernier contrôle remonte à plus de 15
ans donc voilà quand on parle de
contrôle régulier de de d'indicateurs
clair que ce soit la Cour des comptes
que ce soit aujourd'hui les rapports
qu'on a pu avoir en notre possession on
voit bien que quand même 15 ans sans
aucun contrôle ça
questionne alors je vais être plus
précise sur ce que j'aiindique tout à
l'heure les contrats de délégation c'est
pas là qu'aujourd'hui il y a l'ensemble
des indicateurs que j'évoquais les
indicateurs sont produits par les
fédérations dans le cadre des documents
qui viennent décliner et étayer les
contrats de délégation il faut aussi
qu'il y a une sorte de hiérarchie des
documents et il y a parfois des
principes qui seront d'autant plus nets
qu'ils sont exprimés de manière
succinte donc ce que je vise et dans
lequel on a la capacité à les truffer
d'indicateurs faut d'ailleurs qu'il y en
ait pas trop parce que sinon on les noix
c'est les projets sportifs fédéraux
c'est les stratégies sur l'éthique et
l'intégrité qui viennent décliner les
obligations posées par le contrat de
délégation et le contrat d'engagement
républicain qui est signé par chaque
fédération c'est les projets
pluriannuels de performance avec toute
la batterie du sport data hub avec
toutes les données des fédérations qui
remonte dans le système d'information de
l'Agence nationale du
sport je le redis aujourd'hui quand je
veux un chiffre sur une fédération je
l'ai ce qu'il faut c'est aller chercher
les angles morts dans nos dispositifs
juridiques et dans l'acception qui est
donnée à certaines modalités de contrôle
d'où l'attention que je porte à cette
question du contrôle d'honorabilité où
je peux pas laisser certaines fédés dire
que quand on a une licence dirigeant bah
on n'est pas dans le cadre du contrôle
d'honorabilité si on l'est bien sûr
qu'on l'est
tous les bénévoles au contact des
mineurs le sont tous les dirigeants le
sont il y a pas différentes classes de
dirigeants ceux qui y sont ou ceux qui
n'y sont pas donc c'est cette clarté là
qu'il faut aller chercher cette
responsabilisation
là alors
après sur le suivi des fédérations et
les audits moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que depuis que je suis là j'en ai
diligenté 16 et qu'il y en a pas une que
j'ai laissé dans un coin quand j'ai
commencé à voir qu'il y avait un
risque
voilà donc le hand le
hand méritera certainement d'être
contrôlé bien entendu le hand dans les
presque 18 mois maintenant depuis ma
prise de fonction ne m'a pas paru
défaillir sur une dimension ou une autre
quand ils ont eu un problème de
pédocriminalité dans les deux jours qui
ont suivi le problème a été
traité sur la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles les violences à caractère
sexiste sur la parité sur tous ces
sujets ils sont plutôt parmi les fédés
exemplaire donc c'est pas forcément une
mauvaise chose que dans la stratégie de
contrôle on priorise sur les fédés où il
y a des problèmes c'est plutôt une bonne
allocation me semble-t-il des moyens
publics qui ne sont pas comme chacun le
sait extensifs pour le
contribuable alors déjà je je tiens à
dire quand même que ici personne n'a mis
en cause la fédération de de hand on
indique juste que dans les dans les
revues permanentes et donc dans les
contrôles que peut faire que peut être
amené à faire les gesr il n'y a pas eu
de contrôle sur la fédération de depuis
15 ans voilà le dernier le dernier
rapport remonte à 15
ans moi j'entends ce que ce que vous
dites sauf que sur la question des
indicateurs alors déjà j'ai pas très
bien compris peut-être que vous pourrez
nous réexpliquer où sont inscrits ces
indicateurs exactement parce que par
exemple si on prend le contrat de la FFF
il y a quasiment rien je crois sur la
question des VSS en terme d'indicateur
et d'objectif donc c'est inscrit où et
qui finalement définit les indicateurs
parce que j'ai cru comprendre dans votre
réponse que c'était les fédérations qui
faisaient remonter les indicateurs euh
sauf que moi ça me semble quand même
compliqué qu'une fédération décide
elle-même des indicateurs sur lesquels
elle va évaluer son propre travail donc
voilà est-ce que vous pouvez nous
préciser où est-ce que c'est inscrit et
comment sont définis les indicateurs
pour pouvoir évaluer justement les
objectifs qui sont fisqués en les
objectifs qui sont fixés en matière de
VSS par
exemple alors il y a trois types de
documents qui sont produits par les
fédérations les projets sportifs
fédéraux qui sont soumis à l'Agence
nationale du sport et au ministère des
Sports les projets pluriannuels de
performance qui eux porte sur toute la
stratégie de haut niveau et Roxanna m
raciné à nous quant le contrat
d'engagement républicain a été mis en
place avait demandé aux différentes
fédérations de produire un document
étayant le respect des principes
fondamentaux de la République la
fédération à laquelle j'appartenais à
l'époque avait rédigé de manière très
précise très détaillée un tel document
certaines ont davantage
rechigné donc mon point est de dire que
il y a dans ces documents qui portent
sur les trois missions centrales le
développement le haut niveau l'éthique
et l'intégrité les documents qui
comportent les engagements des
fédérations lorsque ce travail est bien
mené au plan
fédéral je ne dis pas qu'il faut pas
renforcer certains contrats de
délégation la directrice des Sports vous
l'a dit ça fait partie des prochains
travaux qu'elle impulsera à ma demande
également mais encore une fois on ne
manque pas de visibilité sur ce que fait
ou pas une
fédération ce qu'il faut c'est que les
missions qui sont les siennes elles les
fassent
bien et on le voit aujourd'hui j'ai
encore là tous les chiffres avec moi on
voit bien celle des fédérations où il y
a un nombre anormalement
important un nombre anormalement bas de
signalement au regard de la base de
licencier j'ai le montant absolu et j'ai
le montant rapporté au nombre de
licenciés ça permet de comprendre
beaucoup de choses sur le contrôle
d'honorabilité c'est exactement pareil
ligne à ligne j'ai un reporting qui peut
me permet de décomter fédération par
fédération le nombre d'identités remonté
dans le système d'information
honorabilité dans ce qu'on appelle le si
dépose en entrée de ce système
d'information sur
l'honorabilité
et moi je le dis je le dis fort vous
savez quand je dis tout ça je le dis
aussi à mes équipes du ministère des
Sports
elles ont tout pour effectuer le
contrôle régalien et l'évaluation
jusqu'au
bout on les a les
éléments ce qu'il faut c'est pousser
plus fort et ne rien laisser passer
alors puisque vous avez évoqué à
plusieurs reprises des chiffres
justement est-ce que vous avez le
chiffre sur le temps de travail euh des
cts qui est consacré au VSS à la à la
FFF il y a
dans les missions des cts une dimension
relative à ces enjeux là mais c'est loin
d'épuiser le champ de leur mission et
pour moi ce qui est un important c'est
que les référents dédiés à ces sujets
spécialement formés et recrutés pour ça
eux soient à 100 % d'exercice de leur
mission sur ces
sujets-là et s'agissant de la FFF il y a
encore un peu de boulot je me suis fait
produire il y a quelques
jours la mise en œuvre du des
préconisations qui ont suivi l'audit en
matière de VSS à Clairefontaine il y a
encore du travail et ils le savent ils
sont dessus c'est aussi le sens du
contrat qui viennent de sortir leur plan
d'engagement sociétal il y a un
adjournamento qui s'est beaucoup
accéléré à la fait des foot mais part de
loin alors peut-être justement sur ces
chiffres le tableau de suivi du temps de
travail des cts tenus par la Direction
des Sports révèle que sur les 41 cts si
figurant 40 ont un temps de travail sur
les VSS qui est estimé entre 2 et 3 % de
leur volume total et individuel
d'activité ainsi le cadre référent VSS
de la DTN de la FFF figure-t-il dans ce
tableau pour 2 % de son
temps la rapporteur mais vous vous
connaissez la vastitude desmissions des
cts non mais quand je l'ai dit quand on
est référent VSS j'espère bien que c'est
100 % de son temps qu'on met quand on
est spécialement formé comme c'est le
cas par exemple à la Fédération de
tennis où j'ai mis en place ce système
là 100 % de la tâche des personnes en
question sont sur ces sujets d'éthique
et d'intégrité quand on est un cts ça
peut vouloir dire plein de choses quand
on est un cts on peut être cts et DTN on
peut être cts et entraîneur fédéral on
peut être cts et entraîneur physique on
peut être cts et et et est chargé de
l'analyse vidéo cts ça veut dire plein
de choses c'est c'est c'est une c'est
une c'est un c'est une formation qu'on a
été cherché pour exercer un certain
nombre de missions de conseiller
techniques sportif donc s'il y a
certains cts qui ont très peu de ces
missions c'est pas forcément anormal il
y a des enjeux sur la formation la
détection le développement le haut
niveau c'est aussi la polyvalence de ces
cts donc je pense que ça n'est pas le
bon indicateur à regarder en revanche et
là je suis totalement avec vous il faut
que dans chaque fédération le déc quand
on nous dit que telle personne est
référent VSS se faire préciser si c'est
à temps plein ou à 60 % du temps ou à 6
% et que ce soit pas une blague que ce
soit pas un référent VSS identifié comme
tel et qu'en réalité il ne passe que 1 %
ou 2 % ou 3 % de son temps sur le sujet
parce que là il y a mal
donne alors justement je pour le
référent VSS en tout cas de la FFF c'est
% référent VSS à la F française de
football tout à l'heure nous avions une
question d'Adrien Gomi toujours le cas
oui merci merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre je tiens à vous
remercier pour tous les éléments très
précis que vous nous avez présenter deux
questions très
rapides dans le prolongement des des
propos qui ont été tenu par mes
collègues il existe d'autres formes de
dérives qu'il faut combattre dans
certains milieux sportifs comme les
phénomènes de radicalisation et de
séparatisme dans la mesure où cela fait
aussi partie du respect du contrat
d'engagement républicain quelles actions
menez-vous pour garantir ce respect
global et deuxième question que
comptez-vous faire pour renforcer le
contrôle d'honorabilité je vous
remercie
alors sur sur la lutte contre la
radicalisation là aussi on a les
chiffres et là aussi on a des outils le
sujet c'est le volontarisme pour s'en
emparer de ces
outils donc les chiffres qu'est-ce
qu'ils nous disent dans
les de mémoire
3400 49 clubs je crois que c'est ça qui
ont fait l'objet de contrôle dans la
période récente il y a que dans 0,8 %
des occurrences que des signaux faibles
de séparatisme ont été
identifié 0,8 % c'est toujours 0,8 % de
trop on a mis en place des référents
éthiques et intégrité dans les
fédérations on a formé au total 160
cadres du ministère des Sports
sur ces sujets j'ai demandé aux
fédérations qui ont 39 effectifs sur ces
sujets-là de renforcer les moyens
qu'elles y attribu et dans 11 d'entre
elles qui sont celles dont on a fait
l'analyse qu'il y avait des risques
spécifiques je les ai engagé dans une
démarche avec le Conseil
interministériel à la prévention de la
radicalisation le
cpdr j'ai décidé que le nombre de
contrôles allait passer de ces 3000 et
quelques à 6000 grâce au renfort
obtenus et chaque fois que nécessaire on
fermera les établissements on coupera
les subventions on l'a fait
récemment en lien avec la région
île-de-fancece dans le champ du
basket aucune possibilité de tolérance
c'est la négation même des valeurs du
sport alors sur le contrôle
d'honorabilité pour moi il y a au moins
deux séries de choses qui doivent être
faites d'abord je souhaite que la PPL de
Sébastien plat qui a été votée à
l'unanimité au Sénat le 15 juin dernier
puisse trouver à être instruite ici le
plus rapidement possible
pourquoi parce qu'elle sanctuarise
l'obligation de signalement aux
autorités
administratives parce qu'elle pose un
nouveau principe d'interdiction
d'exercer aux exploitants de aps
nouvelle faculté nouveaux pouvoirs donné
au préfet qui vient combler un vide
juridique troisème apport majeur elle
dit que même quand il y a effacement du
B2 du casier judiciaire bulletin numéro
2 le B2 on peut interdire d'exercer dès
lors que la personne qui a fait l'objet
d'une condamnation est inscrite au fijis
tenue par le ministère de la
Justice avant hop on effaçait au bout de
6 mois le B2 et hop ça disparaissait du
contrôle
d'honorabilité donc avec le sénateur
avec lequel on a travaillé en lien
d'ailleurs avec des associations de
victimes je pense notamment à celle de
Sarah AB Bitbol on fait en sorte qu'il y
ait une effectivité sur tous ces plans
là mais moi je veux aller plus loin
parce que je me rends compte et vos
travaux y contribuent
beaucoup qu'il y a encore un besoin de
transformation culturel dans No féd sur
ces sujets et donc je veux demander à la
trentaine de ces fédérations souvent
petites qui n'ont pas encore passé la
première ou la seconde sur ces sujets
d'y aller et d'y aller
maintenant sans
tarder ça a déjà trop
attendu je leur demande puisque on a
inscrit fin 21 on a inscrit le contrôle
des éducateurs bénévoles on l'a mis dans
le champ du SI honorabilité je veux que
quand il y a des bénévoles qui font la
buvette qui emmènent les gamins le
weekend qui sont en bord de terrain
régulièrement je veux qu'on leur donne
une licence parce que comme ça ils
rentent dans les fichiers et comme ça on
peut les mettre dans le contrôle
d'honorabilité et quand le contrôle
d'honorabilité il aboutit à une
notification d'interdiction d'exercer ou
d'incapacité d'exercer après décision
judiciaire mais qu'on contrôle
l'effectivité de ça à l'entrée dans les
clubs au départ des clubs pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de la part des éducateurs qui
soient professionnel ou bénévole le
moindre nomadisme de l'évitement à
chaque fois qu'un éducateur veut rentrer
dans un club on contrôle sa carte où on
contrôle sa présence dans le
fichier sinon c'est trop facile je fais
saute puce d'un quop à un autre de la
France et je le redis parce que pour moi
c'est important et je pense que les
travaux ici qui ont été menés depuis 4
mois doivent absolument nous y
conduire de commencer à dire aux
fédérations dont c'est le pouvoir
réglementaire que quand il y a quelque
chose de trop grave qui s'est
produit il y a plus de licence
possible aujourd'hui on a plus d'1,2
million d'identités il faut qu'on monte
en puissance il faut qu'il ait plus une
seule brèche dans ce
système alors vous merci pour ces
éléments sur le contrôle d'honorabilité
je pense qu'on est d'accord sur
plusieurs points là-dessus on a aussi
constaté qu'il avait des difficultés au
niveau de ce contrôle avec des personnes
effectivement qui étaient dont les les
quand au moment du croisement des
fichiers en tout cas qui a été signalé
et qui avait quand même aurit obtenu des
licences notamment auprès de de jeunes
enfants donc je pense que là-dessus il y
aura peut-être effectivement des choses
à à revoir
euh vous avez été vous-même élu au
comité directeur de la Fédération
française de tennis sur sous la liste
ensemble pour un autre tennis de Gill
Moreton l'actuel président de la FFT le
13 février 2021 puis nommé le 5 mars
2021 à la direction générale de la FFT
c'est assez peu commun ce matin on a
évoqué beaucoup justement le la question
des DTN qui par exemple parfois devenait
président de fédération
et là du coup je voulais vous poser la
question c'est peu commun de passer d'un
mandat d'élu au statut de salarié
seulement quelques jours après une
élection est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer dans quel cadre et comment
cela cela s'est mis en
place la vraie réponse c'est que il y a
des moments où dans la vie on fait des
petits coups de
folie c'est un moment très singulier
dans ma vie où j'ai décidé que la vie
dans le grand corporate était pas
totalement faite pour moi et que moi qui
viens du monde du sport j'avais envie
d'y retourner et d'en faire mon métier
voilà ça prend parfois un peu de temps
et parfois ce petit grain de folie on se
dit un jour qu'on a le droit de le
laisser vivre et ce que j'ai envie de
vous dire c'est que j'ai pas regretté un
instant
ça répond pas tout à fait à la question
la question c'est plutôt est-ce que
c'est courant quand on est élu de
devenir DG d'une fédération et voilà
mais
je je je réfléchis je je je sais je je
je crois pas beaucoup je crois pas
beaucoup dans ce sens-là je crois pas
beaucoup il y en a il y en a sans
doute général quand on est
élu c'est plutôt en complément d'une
activité professionnelle bien établie
c'était mon cas dans ce très court labse
de temps où j'étais élu à la Fédération
de tennis en complément de mon rôle de
directrice du digital chez
Carrefour voilà et à un moment j'ai
décidé que ça basculerait et que ça
deviendrait ma fonction à temps plein de
m'occuper du cœur des affaires de cette
fédération et moi voilà je
je je je pense que sur ces sujets et je
connais votre sensibilité à la question
par exemple de savoir si des DTN peuvent
devenir des présidents voilà je pense
que mixer dans une vie les expériences
professionnelles prendre un sujet qui
nous tient à cœur par différents angles
et souvent une source d'enrichissement
DS lors qu'il y a les bons gardesfous
les bons délis de carence la bonne
régularité dans les dépenses de campagne
euh oui moi je suis plutôt pour que la
vie professionnelle soit riche diverse
multiple et que le sport français puisse
compter sur beaucoup de forces vives
d'horizons
variés alors j'entends mais du coup je
vais peut-être poser la question
autrement quelle a été la procédure
suivie pour votre recrutement en tant
que DG de la
FFT les sénateurs Foucher et losac
notamment on préconiser des juris de
recrutement pour les haut postes de
l'encadrement fédéral ainsi qu'une
transparence sur les rémun
rémunération pardon qu'en pensez-vous et
du coup c'est pour ça que je vraiment
poser la question sur le processus de
recrutement quand on est élu sur une
liste quel processus on suit ensuite
pour devenir
DG là la la la
nomination de la directrice générale de
la féd de tennis a été impulsée par le
président de cette fédération et en
consultation avec le
vice-président avec le secrétaire
général et avec le trésorier de cette
fédération qui les uns et les autres
m'ont approché pour me proposer de
prendre ce rôle de directrice
générale pour être complète Gilles
Moreton me l'avait à plusieurs reprise
proposé dans les semaines qui avaient
précédé mon acceptation et j'avais dans
un premier temps puis dans un 2è temps
dit non il a persévéré j'ai pris du
recul je suis parti en vacances j'ai
réfléchi j'ai mûri et il y a un moment
où j'ai dit oui j'ai donc aussitôt
démissionné de mon rôle d'élu puis
démarré euh dans mes fonctions de
directrice générale de la Fée des tennis
le 5 mars après avoir euh mis au point
les termes de mon contrat de travail et
les éléments de ma rémunération euh avec
le quatuor d'acteur que j'ai évoqué et
dans des conditions de totale
transparence vis-à-vis de la direction
de des ressources humaines de la
Fédération de tennis
alors justement concernant votre salaire
de directrice générale vos déclaration
de revenus à la Haute Autorité de la
transparence de la vie publique ne
correspondent pas aux affirmations du
président auditionné par cette
commission d'enquête qui nous indiquait
que vous aviez accepté une rémunération
trois fois inférieure à votre salaire
précédent pour occuper les fonctions de
directrice générale est-ce que vous avez
une explication sur sur les montants
qu'il nous indiquait peut-être je vais
vous donner parcequeon comme c'est
publicque il y a pas de il y a pas de
secret sur les rémunérations que vous
aviez indiqué en 2020 à la Haute
Autorité vous vous aviez indiqué
590947 € puis
582109 en 2021 pour une période de
janvier à mai grosso modo au groupe
Carrefour puis 2000 en 2021 à la FFT
356444 et 165000 737 pour 2022 et en
fait quand on compare les chiffres sur
une année globale on n'est pas du tout
sur le ratio de trois fois donc est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer d'où
proviennent peut-être ces chiffres que
nous que nous a indiqué le président de
la
Fédération le président de la Fédération
Française de Tennis n'a pas
menti et je n'ai pas menti dans mes
déclarations à la Haute
Autorité donc on peut revenir sur ces
sommes si vous le jugez
utile c'est la réponse que je peux vous
faire souhaitez-vous que j'en dise
davantage bon alors on va on va y
aller quand je suis directrice exécutive
membre du COMEX de Carrefour en charge
de la transformation digitale de la data
et de l'expérience client responsabilité
importante dans la grande
distribution le salaire que je perçois
au global tout
compris
est de l'ordre de 144 € par an 400000 en
brut de fixe 400000 en brut de variable
à 100 % et une dot en action de
performance d'à peu près au cours de
l'époque au cours de l'action de
l'époque d' peu près 600000 € 40000
action Carrefour qui devait être autour
de 15 € l'unité je sais pas aujourd'hui
exactement où elles en
sont 400000 +
400000 + 600000 = 1004 ça c'est en
performant au maximum de la performance
avec 100 % d'attribution du
bonus quand j'ai discuté de ma
rémunération à la Fédération de
tennis
ce qui m'a été proposé est un
fixe de 400000 € brut et un bonus
pouvant aller jusqu'à 100000
€. soit une rémunération maximale
possible de 500000 € à comparer avec les
1004 que j'évoqué chez
Carrefour si on ajoute à cela les
régimes de prévoyance et cetera qui sont
plus développés dans les entreprises
privé que dans les fédérations sportives
on est bien sur le coefficient de 3
évoqué par Gilles Moreton tout ceci est
parfaitement
exact
alors une
déclaration d'intérêt et une déclaration
de patrimoine à la
hatvp si on veut les attaquer il faut
les lire jusqu'au
bout donc il faut lire aussi les
éléments relatifs aux actions qui sont
attribuées et quand on connaît un petit
peu le fonctionnement des entreprises
qu'on connaît un petit peu le secteur du
digital et de la technologie on sait que
des talents dans ces secteurs il y a une
partie de rémunération en action de
performance qui est tout à fait capital
c'était 45 % de ma
rémunération c'est déclaré puisque vous
avez été précise je vais l'être à mon
tour c'est déclaré page 4 de ma
déclaration
d'intérêt c'est déclaré dans ma
déclaration de
patrimoine qui dit page
4 40000 actions obtenues via des plans
d'action
gratuites pour un montant total de
€
les déclarations de salaire qui figurent
dans ma déclaration d'intérêt sont des
montants
nets il faut aussi savoir passer du brut
au
net il faut tenir compte des décalages
de trésorerie quand on vous verse un
bonus c'est perçu sur un exercice qui
est souvent l'exercice qui suit l'année
[Musique]
d'éligibilité donc puisque je savais que
ces questions excitait pas mal j'ai pu
refaire à mon tour à l'euro prè les
calculs et je ne ni aucune des virgules
aucun des chiffres ces déclarations sont
parfaitement exactes les montants nets
correspondent parfaitement aux
attestations de rémunération brute et le
coefficient de 3 est exact j'ai donc
renoncé oui au 2/ers de ma rémunération
pour ma passion dans le sport et en
ayant une
rémunération à la Fédération Française
de Tennis très proche de celle de mon
prédécesseur et qui dans mon cas vous
parliez d'indicateur tout à l'heure dans
mon cas a fait l'objet comme c'était mon
souhait et comme c'était ma culture dans
l'entreprise privée d'indicateur de
performance extrêmement détaillé pour
l'attribution du bonus documenté dans
les systèmes d'information RH pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de cette
Fédération Française de
Tennis je je sais
pas si on peut avoir plus de méthodes et
plus
d'éthique dans la manière de se
comporter sur ce
sujet alors pour vous rassurer ça
n'excite pas en tout cas je ne crois pas
ici que qui que ce soit soit excité par
cette question et par ailleurs on est
tout à fait capable de lire les
documents auxquels vous faites référence
seulement nous on a posé des questions
précises au président de la Fédération
il a donné des précisions et des
chiffres qui ne faisaient pas le détail
que vous venez de faire donc il nous
semblait important justement qu'on
puisse revenir en détail là-dessus au vu
de ces déclarations puisque ça nous
corresponda quand il évoque la question
des salaires à aucun moment il ne fait
état de cette distinction que vous
faites dans le cadre de de votre
déclaration donc voilà on on on lit les
documents bien entendu mais ça va mieux
on le
précisant je poursuivrai ces ces
précisions en disant
que ces 500000 € sont à mettre en regard
des 100 millions d'euros dégagés par
cette fédération à raison du business
model particulièrement performant de la
Fédération française de tennis et du
tournoi de Roland
Garros que dans la période où j'ai été
dans cette fédération j'ai parallèlement
augmenté la taille des effectifs baisser
les coûts je suis allée chercher de
nouveaux partenariats j'ai créé de la
valeur de la valeur économique de la
valeur
financière et que c'est une fédération
qui ne touche pas 1 € de subvention
publique
elle est donc en capacité de
payer ceux de ses talents à ce niveau ou
ceux de ses dirigeants à ces niveau
encore une fois sous réserve qu'il y ait
des indicateurs de PER performance
précis
étayé contrôlé dans le cadre d'entretien
d'évaluation de performance que je n'ai
pas souhaité avoir une fois dans l'année
mais à deux reprises avec le président
de la Fédération par
année une question de Monsieur François
piicmal
oui madame la ministre il est pas
question de remettre ici en cause le le
travail que vous aviez eff tué quand
vous étiez une des dirigeantes de la
Fédération française de tennis mais
comprenez qu'on puisse s'interroger
notamment au niveau du sport amateur
qu'une dirigeante de fédération je
prends votre cas puisque c'est celui qui
est exposé ici touche 500000 € par an
alors que bon moi je vois dans ma ville
de Toulouse mais je pense qu'on pourra
le décliner on a plein de clubs qui sont
exang qui n'ont même pas de quoi payer
des équipements les plus élémentaires
pour pouvoir
permettre une pratique correcte est-ce
que vous pensez que il y a pas là à
remédier à ça nous on est pour un
rapport de 1 à 20 bon dans l'entreprise
mais peut-être de manière
générale également dans les fédérations
parce que c'est forcément pour des gens
je vais dire qui touchent le SMIC
voilà le salaire basique en France ça
peut ça peut heurter je pense que vous
le vous pouvez le le comprendre et
l'entendre et je voudrais savoir ce que
ce que vous en
pensez monsieur le député merci de me
dire ça parce que c'est exactement la
raison pour laquelle j'ai fait le
dernier développement que j'ai fait je
comprends très bien que 500000 €
puissent paraître
élevé au regard des standards de vie des
Français et au regard en particulier des
standards de rémunération dans le
sport peu de
fédérations peuvent se
permettre de proposer cela
elles le font encore une fois parce
qu'il y a des business models qui ont
leur spécificités leur force c'est le
cas avec cette man que représente le
tournoi de Roland Garros qui dégage
cette marge brute d'autofinancement de
100 millions d'euros que j'ai évoqué
c'est l'un des tournois l'une des
compétitions sportives les plus rentable
au
monde c'est vraiment la raison pour
laquelle j'ai insisté sur tout ça il y a
pas d'argent du contribuable derrière
cette
rémunération le niveau global des
rémunérations de l'ensemble des cadres
et personnel à la Fédération de tennis
est plus élevé que dans le reste de la
très grande majorité des acteurs du
sport parce qu'il y a cette man de
Roland Garos comme c'est le cas en
Angleterre avec Wimbledon comme c'est le
cas aux États-Unis avec l'US Open comme
c'est le cas en Australie avec
l'Australian Open et comme c'est le cas
pour d'autres très grandes compétitions
de sport en France ou
ailleurs moi ce que je veux dire c'est
que l'argent n'a jamais été mon
moteur aujourd'hui dans les fonctions
qui sont les miennes là encore je divise
par X ma rémunération
et le sujet c'est la passion c'est
l'investissement si je rapporte ma
rémunération actuelle au volume d'heure
que chaque semaine je m'en fourne en
bossant jour nuit
weekend je suis pas bien
payé c'est pas grave j'ai une mission
fondamentale dans un moment important
pour le pays et je suis passionné par ce
que je fais tout entière à mes
responsabilités je crois qu'il faut pas
culpabiliser que dans des grands groupes
qui en ont les moyen on soit payé quand
on est sur des expertises rares
recherché on proportionne les choses
tout en restant bien payé quand on
bascule dans le monde sportif et là dans
le monde politique à nouveau des
coefficients qui sont adaptés au au
contexte c'est comme
ça je pense
que ce qui est important aussi de
rappeler c'est que pour moi la notion de
bonus à sens d'où l'importance des
démarches de performance et de pas
considérer que il y a des acquis en
terme de rémunération voilà c'était le
sens de ma rémunération chez Carrefour
d'être massivement assis sur soit des
actions de performance soit des sujets
de bonus aléatoire et à la Fédération de
tennis j'ai souhaité qu'il ait au moins
20 % de ma rémunération qui soit
elle-même variable soumise à objectif
quantitatif de performance et je
n'aurais pas eu un euro si ces
indicateurs je ne les avais pas perçus
sur ce plan du du bonus en complément de
la partie
fixe moi je veux développer les modèles
économiques du sport je veux que le
sport soit mieux rémunéré que les
acteurs du sport soient mieux rémunérés
parce que je pense que il y a au global
une valeur qui est créée qui n'est pas
suffisamment reconnue et je pense aussi
que l'une des limites actuelles de notre
système globalement y compris dans le
capitalisme tel qu'on le connaît
aujourd'hui et de ne pas rémunérer les
gens suffisamment justement au regard de
leur utilité social et ce que je
pourrais à ma petite mesure faire pour
que des talents et des actions
fondamentales dans le champ du sport
soit mieux rémunéré je le
ferai de la même manière que je
continuerai à soutenir les acteurs
économiques dans le renforcement de leur
modèle y compris jusqu'au start-up comme
je l'ai fait lundi matin en les
accompagnant mieux
aussi merci madame la ministre monsieur
picman vous voulez complter juste quand
même parce que moi j'entends ce que vous
dites et il y a quelque chose
d'intéressant vous dites que ça a été un
choix de votre part et vous comme nous
ici ça a été un choix d'être là où on
est pas quelque chose c'est pas un
travail subi al la plupart de beaucoup
de nos concitoyens ont des travaux subis
il faut un travail parce que il faut
rapporter à manger il faut un travail
souvent exténuant physiquement au nombre
d'heures et ce qu'on retrouve dans les
clubs amateurs c'est souvent des
travailleuses et des travailleurs qui
donnent aussi de leur jour et de leur
nuit et parfois non des clubs qui n'ont
même pas les moyen de pouvoir se payer
par exemple un entraîneur quand c'est
demandé et cetera donc je pense que faut
faut quand même faire attention à ça je
doute pas que vous travaillez que vous
soyez passionné même si on a des
différents politiques certainement mais
c'est le cas de de tous les les
bénévoles qu'on voit enfin d'une grande
partie d'entreux en tout cas euh dans
les clubs et euh je pense que là il y a
moi j'entends que la Fédération de
tennis soit particulière alors je sais
pas ce qu'il en est de la fédération de
golf ou autre euh et que soit il y a un
événement particulier mais euh là il y a
une question à se poser c'est est-ce que
un événement sportif
d'une fédération ne doit pas contribuer
bon à sa fédération mais peut-être à
d'autres aussi fédérations ou acteurs du
monde du sport qui eux sont en
difficultés
financière je pense que c'est une c'est
une très vaste et très importante
question je l'ai dit moi je souhaite que
nos sociétés sachent évoluer vers une
rémunération plus juste au regard de
l'utilité sociale des différents corps
professionnels de
[Musique]
manière symbolique j'ai voulu marquer y
compris pendant la coupe du monde de
rugby par exemple ma reconnaissance
infinie pour le monde des soignants par
des petits gestes anecdotiques mais qui
eux venaientent compléter d'autres
initiatives prise par le gouvernement
auquel j'appartiens et qui n'était pas à
une échelle
anecdotique
il y
a dans cette capacité de certaines
fédérations à dégager de la marge brute
d'autofinancement précisément un
ruissellement qui se fait derrière pour
pouvoir développer les club pour pouvoir
développer les filières de de haut
niveau
et l'engagement bénévole et quelque
chose d'exceptionnel parce que
précisément il y a cette gérosité du
dévouement et de l'investissement j'ai
été dès l'âge de 20 ans bénévole au
service de ma fédération en charge de la
reconversion des sportifs de haut niveau
dès l'âge de 20 ans j'ai continué après
à occuper de nombreuses fonctions
bénévooles dans ma fédération et ensuite
en créant avec des amis une association
où nous étions là aussi à donner notre
temps pour le sport français
gratuitement j'en tire pas un mérite
particulier j' le faisait on le faisait
ensemble parce qu'on était passionné
investi moi ce que je veux c'est que les
bénévoles partout en France ils aient la
reconnaissance de leur action ils aient
la capacité à ce qu'on valide les
compétences qu' développent à ce que les
comptes personnels de formation les
comptes d'engagement citoyen retrac
justement tout ça que la valorisation
des acquis de l'expérience sur laquelle
je travaille ardemment en ce moment et
je reviendrai là-dessus le 5 décembre
lors de la journée du bénévolat oui
permettent de
mieux remercier les bénévoles pour leur
engagement mais ils le font pas pour
l'argent ils le font pour la
transmission ils le font pour le contact
auprès des autres de la jeunesse et mon
boulot sur ce plan c'est notamment de
faire en sorte de les décharger le plus
possible de précisément tout ce qu'ils
n'ont jamais demandé à faire en matière
de tâche administrative ou
autre voilà derrière des rémunération
[Musique]
viennent des diplômes des formations des
expériences professionnelles et encore
une fois pour moi un des progrès
essentiel que notre société doit
parvenir à faire dans les années les
décennies à venir c'est une
reconnaissance plus juste de la
contribution au bien commun des
différents
acteurs madame la ministre une question
sur la FFF monsieur Jean lapère
directeur juridique donc de la FFF a
fini par reconnaître au cours d'une
audition la semaine dernière et et coup
après 1h30 d'audition qu'on savait
depuis longtemps que Monsieur Noël
legrette avait des relation hors code
avec les femmes à quel moment précis
êtes-vous informé de problèmes à la FFF
et par
qui
vous savez informer de problème à la
FFF je pense qu'il m'a suffi de voir le
coup de peinture et le réchaud à gaz sur
les travailleurs migrant au
Qatar pour me dire qu'on avait un
dirigeant absolument hors
sol après voilà il a fallu que l'igsr
mène une enquête ê indépendante à charge
à décharg auditionne récolte un certain
nombre de témoignages gagne la confiance
parfois de certaines victimes ou
victimes présumées pour qu'elles
acceptent à leur tour de briser l'omerta
et qu'elle disent un certain nombre de
choses
h et puis forcément dans ce genre de
contexte
[Musique]
bien sûr des gens ont essayé de me dire
des choses de me parler mais comme
c'était le cas dans des registres très
différents dans d'autres domaines que
j'ai eu à traiter sur le rugby ou ou
autres je suis accessible les gens me
connaissent je suis dans ce monde du
sport depuis plusieurs
années voilà
donc ce qui est important pour moi de
dire c'est
que lorsque l'igsr décide de faire cet
article 40 je souligne bien dans chacun
de mes éléments de langage que c'est au
procureur qu'il reviendra de qualifier
sur le plan pénal les faits dont il
s'agit et dans le cadre de la conférence
de
presse que j'ai pu faire à l'issue au
moment de la réédition des
conclusions de
l'igsr j'ai repris les termes de leur
conclusions qui était
l'existence de propos ou de SMS les uns
ambigus les autres à caractère
sexuel j'ai toujours
veillé à utiliser toute l'information
dont nous disposions et à rester à ma
place rien qu'à ma place à ne me pas me
prendre pour une juge et à laisser
encore une fois les autorités euh
prendre leur responsabilité la justice
d'un côté et elle le fera elle rendra
ses conclusions lorsqu'elle sera prête
et les instances qui les unes après les
autres le comité exécutif le conseil
d'éthique d'autres instances du monde du
foot en viennne à dire qu'elle
souhaitait à un moment la démission de
Noël Leret parce qu'il n'avait plus la
légitimité pour piloter cette fédération
voilà ce que je
pense pouvoir résumer sur ce plan
j'espère avoir répondu
à à l'intégralité de votre
question Madame Florence hardardoin nous
dit qu'elle avait échangé qu'elle a eu
un entretien avec avec vous et qu'elle a
plus qu'elle a pu vous exprimer les
comportements de inapproprié de Monsieur
Noël
leet c'est exact que j'ai eu un ENT
entretien avec elle elle a souhaité me
parler voilà donc j'ai entendu ce
qu'elle avait à me dire et en même temps
ça n'est pas moi qui était en charge de
l'audit donc j'ai toujours demandé à
chacune des personnes qui a eu Florence
mais il y a eu d'autres femmes qui ont
souhaité à certains moment me parler me
dire des choses que chacune puisse
s'exprimer dans le cadre juridique prévu
pour ça avec les garanties prévues pour
ça en
terme de formalisation de leurs
témoignages de signature de leur
déclaration de préservation de
l'anonymat de leur déclaration et je
pense que cet audit a été de bout en
bout mené de manière exemplaire par
Caroline Pascal Patrick LAVOR à la tête
de l'inspection générale et leur équipe
d'inspecteur le trio qui a fonctionné
sur cette
inspection on l'a souvent entendu euh
dans le cadre de cette commission
d'enquête euh d'ailleurs dans plusieurs
fédérations dans plusieurs affaires
lorsque les victimes soit se sont
exprimés soit lorsqu'on a eu des
témoignages du fait que souvent il y
avait plusieurs personnes qui étaient
informées qui étaient au courant de ce
qu'il se passait et qui n'ont pas
dénoncé ou en tout cas fait de
signalement par rapport au fait dont ils
avaient connaissance c'est le cas
notamment à la FFF où aujourd'hui encore
ça a été dit ça a été rappelé monsieur
lapère nous a quand même dit au bout
d'unehure et3 que tout le monde
connaisseit les comportements hors code
de Monsieur Legret qu'est-ce qu'il se
passe pour toutes ces personnes
finalement qui étaient informé et qui
n'ont pas signalé et pas euh enfin voilà
pas fait de signalement alors qu'ils
étaient informé de des faits qui se
passaient au sein de leur fédération
puis qu'il reste encore des personnes
aujourd'hui au sein de la FFF et dans
d'autres aussi
oui il y a une enquête judiciaire qui
est en cours et c'est des personnes qui
peuvent être auditionné
encore moi qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
je vous dise je
j'espère que ces
précédents nous rendrons tous
collectivement meilleurs plus aguéris
plus affuté je pense qu'ils ont vu que
il y avait une ministre dont la main ne
tremblerait pas si de tels agissements
venaient à se
reproduire voilà je pense que
[Musique]
euh ce que je veux redire puisque vous
m'en donnez l'opportunité c'est
que signaler c'est pas une
option signaler c'est une obligation
morale s'agissant de mineur c'est même
une obligation pénale quand on est
détenteur de l'autorité publique c'est
une obligation pénale là aussi article
40 quand on est un président président
de fédération on est assimilable
puisqu'on est à la tête d'une fédération
délégataire de service public à une
autorité publique donc on doit faire un
article 40 quand on constate des
choses et je ne peux que me féliciter
que la PPL de Sébastien plat affirme au
effort dans la loi qui j'espère encore
une fois sera voté le plus rapidement
possible ici à
l'Assemblée il y a une obligation de
signalement des clubs vers les préfets
des fédération vers le ministère c'est
une obligation et c'est
même en terme de prescription important
de
rappeler c'est une évolution du droit
depuis 2018 qu' est jamais trop tard
pour se
réveiller quand on est au courant des
faits les plus graves contre des
mineurs la prescription elle ne démarre
qu'au moment où les faits auraient dû
cesser pour 6 ans il y a du
temps donc moi c'est un appel puisque
vous m' donnez l'opportunité à tous ceux
qui ont vu des choses et qui ont des
suspicions de le signaler ça veut pas
dire d'accuser ça veut dire de donner la
possibilité qu'il y ait une enquête et
des vérifications dans toute la
diligence
nécessaire signaler c'est sauver des
vies Roxan maranou a indiqué à la
commission un président ne peut plus
dire qu'il ne savait pas ce qui se
passait dans son dans un tel club
aujourd'hui tout remonte en centrale de
manière à ce que la ministre connaisse
tous les sujets pensez-vous que cet
objectif soit
atteint en tout cas moi j'ai une
transparence absolu de la part de la
direction des sports dans le respect qui
lui-même doit être
absolu du contradictoire et
donc des droits de la
défense et du nécessaire anonymat qui
doit accompagner des procédures
judiciaire en
cours mais je l'ai dit si des décisions
ne sont pas prises ça n'est pas faute
d'avoir l'information ou la capacité
d'agir d'où mon appel à ce que chacun
prenne jusqu'au bout dans l'exercice de
son pouvoir qu'il soit disciplinaire
administratif
ou judiciaire c'est
responsabilité notre droit est assez
bien
fait
merci alors peut-être une question sur
le COJO dont on a beaucoup parlé ces
derniers ces derniers mois comment
jugez-vous en en tant que ministre en
charge des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 les informations
relatives au montant et au montage
financier pour la rémunération du
président du
COJO ces rémunérations
elles correspondent dans leur montant
plafond qui prévaut
pour les dirigeants des établissements
publics c'est des
seuil autour de 400 500000 € j'ai pas le
l'exactitude c'est ce type de plafond
qu'on trouve pour l'exercice des
responsabilités de patron
d'établissement
public s'agissant des modalités moi ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que ce sont
des modalités qui ont été vues par
l'ENSEM emble des instances qui avaient
à en
connaître bien
sûr les
services des ressources humaines du COJO
encore une fois contrat documentés
tracés dans les systèmes mais aussi tous
les organes internes d'audit de contrôle
en matière
déontologique qui sont au cœur de la
gouvernance du COJO et avec des acteurs
qui sont parmi si je fais référence à un
Jean-Marc Sauvé j'aurais pu en citer
d'autres parmi les plus
[Musique]
éminents aux fonctionnaires que notre
état est plus
comptié ces procédures ont été regardées
elles ont été calibrées auditées voilà
moi j'ai pas dans mon rôle de ministre
de commentaires supplémentaires à faire
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que le
contrôle du cojot comme d'ailleurs de la
solidéo il est
multidimensionnel le COJO fait
probablement partie des entités
aujourd'hui les plus contrôlés de France
et c'est
normal les équipe à chaque fois qu'elles
en ont eu la nécessité
ou qu'elles y ont été appelées on
coopérer de manière pleine et entière
avec la justice et la justice fait son
travail sans entrave et avec la dilig
quel juge nécessaire d'y
mettre l'INSEP est le seul établissement
public placé sous le contrôle du
ministère en charge des sports nous
avons été très surpris je pense
plusieurs d'entre nous lors des 2 heures
d'audition que nous avons mené avec les
responsables de l'inicecep de la très
grande impréparation des nombreuses
approximations des inexactitudes pardon
voire parfois des contradictions dans
les répes qui nous ont été apporté
concernant la sécurité les luttes contre
les VSS notamment notre visite sur place
a confirmé qu'il n'existait pas
forcément de planans stratégique et
opérationnel clair sur les questions et
que la sécurité devait être grandement
améliorée euh la Commission en tout cas
par le biais de madame la Présidente et
moi-même on vous a adressé un courrier à
ce sujet sur lequel on n pas eu de
réponse jusqu'à présent peut-être que
vous avez des éléments à nous préciser
sur justement les interrogations qu'on a
fait porter à votre connaissance
absolument et je vous remercie de de ce
courrier je je l'ai là sous les yeux
c'est un courrier qui est daté du 10
octobre qui a été enregistré par le
bureau des cabinets en entrée le timbre
et là le 16
octobre sur lequel donc je vous dois et
je vous ferai une réponse écrite elle
est aujourd'hui en cours j'attendais
notre audition pour pouvoir vous vous
l'adresser et ce que je veux vous
exprimer la dire directrice des sports
le sait c'est
que c'est pas une lettre qui m'a fait
plaisir et c'est pas une lettre comme
j'ai envie d'en recevoir d'autres et
vous avez raison de soulever les points
qui vous ont préoccupés et pour vous
montrer notre communion de détermination
sur ces sujets sans attendre d'avoir
votre courrier entre les mains dès le 11
octobre j'ai évoqué que le courrier que
vous m'avez adressé a été enregistré
dans les systèmes le 16 octobre dès le
11 octobre donc avant d'avoir reçu votre
courrier j'ai fait écrire ce courrier
par la directrice des sports au
directeur général de l'INSEP pour lui
demander de renforcer de manière
extensive tout ce qu'il avait à faire
sur le champ des VSS en terme de
procédure d'alerte de signalement de
communication d'explication sur les
modalités de prise en charge des
victimes et de prévention des situations
à risque ainsi que de systématisation de
la la formation de tous les
publics j'ai fait dans les jours qui ont
suivi un point détaillé avec la
sous-directrice en charge du pilotage de
tout cela pour faire le point sur tous
les leviers que nous avons besoin de
renforcer à l'INSEP mais aussi dans les
établissements et un plan d'action
complet est en train d'être finalisé sur
ces sujets-là qui ira jusqu'à mieux
décliner au cœur de la convention
d'objectifs et de moyens de
l'INSEP ces exigences et de les décliner
également au cœur des conventions de
collaboration entre l'INSEP et les
différentes fédérations il faut mailler
juridiquement le problème et faire en
sorte que sur tous ces véhicules on
réhausse le niveau d'exigence et de
mobilisation je sais qu'il vous est
revenu par ailleurs sur le sujet de
l'article 40 au sujet de Claire Palou et
sur le timing dans lequel il l'a fait
avant son rendez-vous devant votre
commission il a par ailleurs d'ors et
déjà pris la décision de multiplier par
de la taille de la cellule en charge des
violences et j'ai rappelé à la
directrice des sports et à la
sous-directrice en charge du contrôle de
ses établissements que je voulais qu'en
matière disciplinaire les choses soient
menées avec plus d'exigence car ce que
je n'ai pas compris dans l'affaire Palou
c'est que la commission de discipline
n'est pas elle aussi été saisie je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure l'enjeu de
l'articulation entre l'admin le
judiciaire et le disciplinaire est et
fait la force de notre
dispositif donc ça n'est pas suffisant
de su de saisir la justice dans ce type
de circonstances il faut aller au bout
de ces responsabilités en matière
disciplinaire alors
peut-être deux deux interrog enfin une
interrogation et peut-être une
précision ma question c'est plutôt enfin
est-ce que vous étiez informé qu'il y
avait des dysfonctionnements de ce typep
où est-ce qu'il y avait eu des alertes
avant cette audition sur comment était
mise en œuvre justement les directives
en matière de lutte contre les VSS et et
des dispositifs de la compréhension au
non d'ailleurs des dispositifs type
signalement type article 40 au niveau de
l'INP et la deuxième chose je ne sais
pas si vous avez eu l'occasion de voir
l'audition de Claire Palou ou pas mais
je pense que oui l'une des pistes
qu'elle évoque dans le fait qu'il n'y
ait pas eu de sanction disciplinaire
c'est que la la personne mise en cause
en question serait un potentiel
médaillable aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques l'année prochaine et que
c'est pour ça que la Fédération n'a pas
agi ainsi que
l'unicep non enfin
alors est-ce que j'avais une alerte sur
l'INP non pas non pas de manière
spécifique là encore je pense qu'il faut
proportionner les choses vous
savez la parole c'est quand même libéré
dans les dernières années lescoutes
aussi s'il y avait eu des problèmes de
grande ampleur à l'INSP les choses
auraient été
dit aurait été ch au moins aurait été
murmuré dans les couloirs et cetera ce
type de rumeurs qui me sont parvenus sur
d'autres sujets j'ai évoqué le foot et
le rugby ne me sont pas remontés à
l'inep qui pourtant accueil année après
année des générations entières de jeunes
champions de jeunes au potentiel sportif
donc là encore je pense qu'il faut
ramener à leur juste proportion les
dysfonctionnements qui se sont produits
maintenant il y en a eu des
dysfonctionnements il faut les traiter
en tirer les leçons c'est ce qu'on a
fait à travers ce courrier et le plan
d'action du directeur général est
attendu pour le plus prochain conseil
d'administration qui aura lieu dans les
toutes prochaines semaines avant la fin
de cette
année sur la protection vous
savez moi je vais être très clair
là-dessus des médailles oui mais pas à
tout
prix pas à n'importe quel prix et pas au
prix du renoncement à nos valeurs et à
nos convictions parce qu'on euvre pas
seulement pour le court terme on uvre
pour le long terme donc l'exemplarité
elle est un impératif donc personne
n'est protégé dans le sport français et
surtout pas par la ministre personne
je dis
souvent que les champions encore plus un
devoir d'exemplarité parce qu'ils sont
regardés ils inspirent notre
jeunesse donc ne pensez pas du tout
qu'il y ait de système de de protection
il y a pas de vache sacrée il y a euh
des êtres humains qui doivent être
respectés et de la même manière que je
dis on n' pas des résultats à tout prix
quand je m'insurge contre une certaine
idée de la haute performance par exemple
dans la
gym c'est précisément pour envoyer ce
message que non c'est
pas de la sueur du sang et des larmes le
sport c'est du sens c'est de
l'âme mais c'est pas de la sueur du sang
et des larme et c'est pas des violences
et c'est pas de la destruction au nom de
l'exigence la vraie exigence c'est celle
qui embarque la bienveillance et le
respect du
sportif je voudrais dire là-dessus que
je voulais prouver d'ailleurs dans les
semaines
écoulé
[Musique]
Nice qui est parmi les équipes en tête
du championnat de Ligue 1 aujourd'hui
bon j'ai pas hésité sur Youssef hatal à
dire que c'était juste pas possible
d'accepter qu' ce type de propos
totalement inacceptable en matière de
cautionnement d'appel à la violence ou
au terrorisme
ou choses qui vont
avec
sur notre autre athlète pareil pas de
vache sacrée j'ai dit quand il a
commencé à avoir des des propos
totalement consternants tellement il é
déplacé sur les réseaux sociaux j'ai pas
hésité à élever la voix et à dire que
c'était juste pas
possible j'ai oublié son nom maedin
mekissi mekissi mayedine
mekissi multimédailler tout médailler
tout multimédailler olympique qu'il
soit trop important l'exemplarité donc
personne n'est protégé personne ne doit
être
protégé
alors j'ai quelques questions concernant
l'ANS donc peut-être je vais toutes les
poser d'un coup comme ça au moins vous
pourrez répondre à à ces
questions la ns a été créé pour être un
opérateur de l'État et pourtant dans les
auditions et les différentes personnes
qu'on a pu entendre aussi cette agence
donne l'impression de se substituer
parfois au ministère des Sports et
parfois au fonctionnaires placés par
l'État au sein des fédération je pense
au DTN et même à des établissements
publics reconnus du champ de la
performance comme l'INSP comment est-ce
que vous garantissez que les actions de
l'ANSS soient bien contrôlé par les
services de votre ministère plus
largement quels sont les critères de
sélection qui prévalent aux attributions
financières de la NS et par et quels
sont les critères d'évaluation de
l'efficacité de ces attributions parce
que quand on les a auditionné j'avoue
que c'était pas très clair la manière
dont justement était attribué les les
subventions sur quelle évaluation donc
est-ce que vous de votre côté vous avez
peut-être plus d'éléments euh qu'est-ce
qui est mis en place en terme de
procédure avec l'ANSS pour en garantir
la bonne utilisation de ces subventions
est-ce qu'il y a un contrôle régulier
des pièces justificatif par exemple par
le ministère des
sports sur les anciens fonds
CNDS une partie de l'action d'évaluation
de l'ANSS est délégué aux fédérations
pour attribuer des financements au clubs
de ces mêmes fédérations n'y voyez-vous
pas un problème de gouvernance ou à tout
le moins un problème d'indépendance juge
et parti euh entre les deux dans les
conventions d'objectifs pluriannuels des
fédérations quel est le rôle de la ns
euh
et particulièrement finance-t-elle des
actions pour lutter contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes si oui quels
objectifs fixez-vous vous fixez-vous au
niveau du ministère quel contrôle
avez-vous mis en place et quel est votre
bilan comme ça j'ai tout posé d'un coup
oui je pense que vous savez quand je
suis
arrivée dans mes fonctions dès l'été qui
a suivi le 18 juillet j'ai fait un
séminaire à l'inep pour justement
essayer de remettre la clarté nécessaire
dans les rôles et responsabilités de de
chacun et j'ai fait faire à mes équipes
pour les partager aux acteurs du sport
français des schémas très clair
établissant les liens contractuels
entre les différents
acteurs direction des sports agence
nationale du sport l'INSEP les CREPS les
établissements et les différentes
fédérations avec leurs structures
fétières que sont le cpsf et le
CNOSF donc entre ces différents acteurs
j'ai affirmé un principe qui est de dire
la direction des sports
est en charge du régalien
elle donne les grandes orientations
stratégiques elle procède à l'évaluation
mais l'agence nationale du sport est
l'opérateur des politiques publiques
sportives et à ce titre là
elle pilote le programme ambition bleue
sur la haute
performance et elle pilote l'ensemble
des actions de
développement sur tout le champ des
clubs et du déploiement de la pratique
sportive auprès des licenciés dans les
territoires ces deux programmes
stratégiques font l'objet d'une
contractualisation entre l'agence et les
fédérations qui prennent différents
visages selon le champ concerné on
appelle ça les projets pluriannuels de
performance pour le haut niveau et les
projets sportifs fédéraux pour la partie
développement ils sont
eux-mêmes avec un chapeau commun qui
explique le projet fédéral et je l'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure à la demande à
l'époque de Roxan maracinéanou au
lendemain de l'été 2021 il y avait un 4è
document qui déclinait les les
engagements en matière d'éthique au
titre du respect du contrat d'engagement
républicain
à partir de cette
contractualisation qui repose sur une
vision stratégique que propose la
fédération à l'agence au regard des
impulsions stratégiques que cellees-ci a
posé il y a un certain nombre
d'indicateurs et il y a des volumes de
financement qui sont
attribués compte tenu du nombre
d'athlètes présentés aux Jeux Olympiques
aux Jeux paralympiques contenu du nombre
d'athlètes qui sont éligibles aux aides
personnalisées c'est-à-dire
l'accompagnement sur le plan socio
professionnel contrat d'insertion
professionnelle convention d'aménagement
vers l'emploi parfois contrat de mesenat
ou contrat d'image dans le cadre du PACT
de
performance sur le
champ
fédéral la nouvelle philosophie qui
diffère de l'époque du CNDS c'est que
l'agence délègue sur le champ du
développement des enveloppes qu'il
revient aux fédérations de décliner
ensuite à la maille des clubs territoire
par territoire les fédérations sont donc
responsabilisé sur l'allocation
financière des moyens qui lui leur sont
dévolu par l'agence vers les ligues les
comités et les
clubs en regard de
cela dans le cadre du dialogue de
gestion que j'évoqué tout à l'heure et
du suivi qui est fait par l'Agence du
respect de ces différents
documents une évaluation est faite et
les financements peuvent être
ajustés à la baisse à la
hausse en
fonction aussi est-ce que c'est une
fédération engagée sur les jeux d'hivers
est-ce que c'est les Jeux d'été quelle
est la priorité du
moment quel est le volume de coach qui
peuvent émerarger au titre du plan coach
mis en place par l'agence nationale qui
là aussi sont au cœur des projets
pluriannuels de performance des
fédérations quels sont les contrat de
préparation olympique que de grands
entraîneurs ont en complément du plan
coach dans le cadre du Plan ambition
bleu c'est toute cette déclinaison tout
ce
maillage conventionnel d'objectifs et de
suivi qui sont mis en place et encore
une fois ce que j'ai demandé à la
direction des sports d'impulser c'est
pour toutes les matières dont elle a la
responsabilité ou toutes les matières
sur lesquelles elle a une responsabilité
d'évaluation il y ait dans le cadre du
dialogue de gestion des rendez-vous pris
selon une matrice des risques avec
chaque fédération et qu'à l'issue de
chaque entretien il y ait la
matérialisation dans une lettre de tous
les points qui méritent un renforcement
en terme d'action ou de suivi pour
l'avenir ce dialogue de gestion je le
dis était éteint on se contentait de
documents écrits d'échanger des
documents qu'en réalité les services ne
lisaient pas ou ne lisaient pas
suffisamment donc ce pilotage humain mis
avec du sens sur les choses avec des
prix priorité assumé et avec un suivi
effectif derrière c'est ça qu'on veut et
on veut que cette philosophie se
décline également entre le ministère et
ses établissements publics d'où le
renforcement des contrats de performance
des conventions d'objectif et de moyens
et vous pouvez pas imaginer par exemple
à l'égard du cpsf et du CNOSF le soin et
le temps qui ont été mis par mes équipes
et cell de ces de de structures pour
venir à bout de nos conventions
d'objectifs et de moyens qu'on vient de
renouveler avec des indicateur hyper
précis on peut vous produire tout ça des
tableaux entiers Excel revu X fois par
les équipes et ensuite par mois et par
les dirigeants de ces instances pour
s'assurer que les moyens étaient
correctement fléchés priorisés qu'on
soit au rendez-vous des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques et qu'on soit au
rendez-vous du développement de la
pratique qui doit venir en é itage de
ces jeux sans perdre de vue le
régalien ce sont plusieurs millions
d'euros de financement qui sont piloté
de cette
manière peut-être juste sur la manière
parce que vous nous avez dit qu'il y
avait des indicateurs pour
justement je vais dire ventiler euh les
les subventions euh mais comment
s'effectue le contrôle parce que j'ai
posé la question est-ce que c'est un
contrôle sur pièce pour vérifier par
exemple que les actions ont bien été
mises en œuvre comment ça se passe que
c'est du déclaratif est-ce qu'il y a des
contrôles sur pièces juste voilà je je
repose la question entretiens qui sont
menés il y a une réédition de compte à
chaque fois que l'agence l'exige d'une
fédération et il y a ce dialogue de
gestion qui est un moment humain
d'échange qui complète le suivi des
contrats d'objectif et de performance
par la Direction des Sports
ce dialogue de gestion encore une
fois ça fait un an que j'ai remis
l'énergie
dedans et pour moi on n'est pas encore à
la cible on doit monter en
puissance avec la bonne cartographie des
risques qui permet de regarder fédé par
féé on va pas revisiter l'intégralité de
tout on va regarder les points de
vulnérabilité et là on lâche
pas alors je
comprends la question du dialogue de
gestion avec les différentes fédérations
mais comment est-ce que on contrôle que
les actions qui ont été fléchées et
financées ont bien été mis en
œuvre est-ce que c'est juste on fait on
fait le dialogue de gestion donc c'est
un entretien donc les personnes viennent
déclarent qu'elles ont fait des choses
ou elles amènent des éléments écrits des
preuves de ce qui a été mis en place
même des éléments et il y a à direction
des sports un bureau dédié au suivi des
fédérations un bureau dédié au suivi des
établissements et qui demande
régulièrement la production de documents
de suivi par rapport au documents maître
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure et si je
prends l'exemple de Claude hesta et de
ses équipes de Yan kuchra et des équipes
en charge de la haute performance elles
ont des entretien régulier avec les
équipes
fédérales qui permet de faire le point
sur l'avancée des priorités qui ont été
inscrites dans les projets de
performance et juste peut-être pour
revenir là-dessus euh vous m'avez pas
dit si laans finance des actions de
lutte contre les VSS
oui elle le fait elle le fait à hauteur
de plus de 3 millions d'euros je crois
que c'est 3,3 million d'euros exactement
elle le fait et elle le fait en
complément des moyens qui sont mobilisés
par la direction des Sports ellees-même
à hauteur de 600000 € en matière
d'accompagnement des associations de
victimes nous avons terminer les
questions madame la ministre merci à
vous merci de votre disponibilité euh
pour une audition qui devait durer
2h nous sommes pas loin de à plus de 3h
donc je vous remercie je pense que même
la rapporteur
également n'hésitez pas à revenir vers
nous et même si vous souhaitez aussi
nous partager des éléments dont vous
avez parler tout à l'heure euh nous
sommes bien sûr à l'écoute tout ça bien
sûr dans le but de de nourrir cette
commission d'enquête et notamment les
propositions qui en sortiront merci à
vous merci beaucoup merci à à vous et
merci de contribuer à nous faire
progresser